EVERYONE.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING.
TODAY WE HAVE FOUR PANELS ON
DIFFERENT AREAS WITHIN HUMAN
SERVICES COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING.
WHETHER RESERVATION.
IN CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND ALL THESE PROGRAM AREAS ARE
CONNECTED IN THAT THEY SERVE
ADULTS CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
NEED.
A FEW NOTES BEFORE WE BEGIN.
I ONCE AGAIN AUS THAT OUR
PANELISTS -- MAINTAIN THEIR
REMARKS OR LIMIT THE REMARKS TWO
UNDER THREE MINUTES.
PLEASE.
I ALSO ELSE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
COMMENTS BE LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE.
AND OUR STAFF WILL HOLD UP A
LITTLE SIGN JUST REMINDING YOU
YOU'RE AT THE ONE MINUTE MARK.
WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER.
ONE I WANT TO WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION ALSO KNOWN AS C. C. L..
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PROBABLY
REACTING DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES -- AND WE'RE
VERY HAPPY TO PRESENT ON OUR
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING OR CCL
AS YOU MENTIONED.
TODAY -- THIS IS OUR SECOND
LARGEST DIVISION -- IN THE
DEPARTMENT RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING NEARLY SEVENTY
THOUSAND FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
EVERYTHING FROM INFANT CARE UP
TO ADULT WAS SENIOR CARE AND HOT
WITH INCLUDING HOSPICE AT THE
END -- AND SO WITH ME TODAY IS
PAM TO CROSS WHO IS THE DEPUTY
OF OUR COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION -- WHO'S GOING TO DO
THE ANSWER THE QUESTIONS FOR YOU
YOUR AGENDA DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
OF LAYING OUT THE BACKGROUND IN
THE HISTORY OF THE DEPARTMENT SO
WE THOUGHT.
WITH YOUR A PERMISSION WE WILL
GO STRAIGHT TO THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU SO THE FIRST QUESTION
IS.
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
INSPECTION FREQUENCY AND THE
CONFIDENCE LEVEL TO OBTAIN AND
REACH ANNUAL INSPECTIONS AS
PRESCRIBED IN CURRENT LAW.
SO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE RECEIVED
FUNDING TO DO AT INCREASE OUR
INSPECTIONS FOR ALL THREE
PROGRAMS CHILD CARE CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL ADULT SENIOR CARE
FROM FIVE YEARS TO THREE YEARS.
SO WE BACK BEGAN THAT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SEVEN AND THEN IN
TWENTY EIGHT TEAM WE WENT TO TWO
YEARS FOR CHILDCARE AND
CHILDRENS RESIDENTIAL AND STATE
AT THREE YEARS FOR CHILD CARE
WHEN WE MET THOSE MANDATES ABOUT
98% BOTH OF THOSE YEARS. TWENTY
NINETEEN WERE AT UP -- TO ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS FOR ADULTS SENIOR
CARE AND THEN TWO YEARS FOR
CHILDCARE AND CHILDRENS
RESIDENTIAL SO.
AND THERE'S AS ALL SPEAK TO AT
THE END THERE'S MANY IN THE
BUDGET TO DO ANNUAL INSPECTIONS
FOR CHILD CARE SO.
THAT IS GREAT NEWS TO WRITE WE
DO SEE THAT THE CHILD CARE
CENTERS ARE ON TRACK TO BE
VISITED ANNUALLY WITH THE THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THAT WE
RECEIVED AND I KNOW THAT.
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THIS --
MAY EIGHTH.
AT THE SIDE ON MAY EIGHTH
HEARING SO WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THAT THAT IS GREAT NEWS YEAH
IT'S CURRENTLY IN STATURE THAT
THREE YEARS BUT CORRECT.
KAY AND THAT'S WHAT WE INTENDED
TO TALK ABOUT TODAY IS THE THREE
YEARS BUT I THINK WE'RE ON TRACK
FOR THE ONE YEAR.
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN WE
CAN DO IT.
SEC ANY QUESTIONS NO NO PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY I JUST WANTED LIKE
THAT THIS IS EXCITING NEWS I
WANTED TO BE SURE WE WENT OVER
ON THE SAME PAGE ON THAT YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS IMPOSSIBLE
IMPEDIMENTS TO THE NEW
INSPECTION TOOLS SO THE NEW
INSPECTION TOOLS -- THERE'S A
LOT OF BENEFITS TO IT WHO --
WE'RE STILL GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS WE JUST COMPLETED OUR
FIRST PILOT WITH WITH SENIOR
KERR.
WE HAVE A WE DID OVER THREE
HUNDRED FACILITIES AND THE PILOT
WITH TWENTY L. P. A.'S SO WE
RECEIVED A LOT OF INFORMATION
AND DATA FROM THAT TO WHERE
WE'RE UPDATING THE TOOLS TO
PROVIDE MORE MORE EFFICIENCIES
MAKE THEM SHORTER.
SO THE TOOL IS DEVELOPED AROUND
THE REGULATORY STRUCTURE --
DIFFERENT FROM HOW THE KIT WAS
STILL IN THE IN THE INSPECTION
WE GET MORE OF A OF A WELL
BALANCED -- LOOK AT HELP THE
HELP THE FACILITY IT GOES AROUND
IT'S BUILT ON DOMAINS LIKE
PHYSICAL PLANT MEDICATIONS
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS --
RESIDENT RIGHTS AND SO IT'S
FOCUSED ON ALL OF THOSE AREAS
AND IT'S ALSO GOT THE ABILITY
FOR CONTINUALLY UPDATED THAT
WHEN THERE'S NEW LEGISLATION WE
UPDATE IT SO IT'S RIGHT THERE IN
THE TOOL WE DON'T HAVE A
STANDARD COM -- COMPREHENSIVE
TOOL FOR OUR PROGRAM SO IT'S ALL
THE TRAINING IN THEIR HEADS THAT
THEY THINK THEY'VE GOT TO GO
AROUND AND AND CHECK MOST OF
THAT NOW WE HAVE A STANDARD.
ANOTHER BENEFIT IS THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE A BASELINE OF DATA
WE USE OUR DATA TO SEE WHERE WE
IDENTIFY CHALLENGES IN IN
CHILDCARE OR ADULT SENIOR KERR --
WE'VE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TRAINING IN THOSE AREAS WHERE
WE'RE SEEING THEY'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS WE'VE HAD SYMPOSIUMS TO
TRAIN.
EVEN THE STAFF IN THE FACILITIES
AS WELL AS OUR OWN STAFF LIKE
FOR INSTANCE PRESSURE ULCERS
THEY'VE HAD.
YOU KNOW AT A LARGE INCREASE IN
PRESSURE ULCERS IN OUR ADULT
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES IN THAT
THAT THEY'RE NOT CLINICIANS SO
WE'RE TRAINING THEM ON HOW.
TO PREVENT THEM AND HOW TO YOU
KNOW WHEN THEY CHANGE
MEDICATIONS WITH AN ADULT HOW
THEY INTERACT TOGETHER THEY
MIGHT LOOK FOR THINGS LIKE
SLEEPING MORE.
MOVING THEM AROUND GIVING THEM
ACTIVE SO I MEAN THERE'S THINGS
THAT WE TRAIN OUR LPH TO TRAIN
THEM FOR BEST PRACTICES CHILD
CARE WE DID -- CHALLENGING BEING
CHILDREN WITH CHALLENGING
BEHAVIORS HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT
WE TRAINED YOU KNOW BOTH THE
CARE GIVERS AS WELL AS OUR OWN
STAFF.
AND THAT'S ALL.
PART OF THIS NEW TOOL IS TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION WHEN
THEY GO OUT AND DO AN INSPECTION
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHILE
THEY'RE OUT AT THE FACILITY
INSTEAD OF DECIDING THEM AND AND
AND WHAT WE WERE DOING IN THE
PAST.
USING ARMED FORCE MEANT.
AND THEN WE WERE JUST SHUTTING
THEM DOWN SO WE WERE SEEING IT
WASN'T DOING ANY GOOD WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF BEDS IN THE STATE
AND SO THAT THAT IS THAT WAS THE
IMPETUS FOR THE NEW TOOLS WE
WERE SEEN WE WERE IN THERE DOING
pLATER THEY'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
THAT WERE NOT IDENTIFIED WHEN WE
WERE IN THERE PRIOR WITH THE KIT --
AND THEN SOME OF THE IMPEDIMENTS
IT'S CERTAINLY THE TOOL TOOK
LONGER IN THE PILOT BUT IT'S A
IT'S A COMPREHENSIVE TOOL AS
OPPOSED TO THE KIT WHICH IS AS A
SHORT ABBREVIATED TOOL.
SO FROM THAT COMPREHENSIVE TOOL
WE'RE GOING TO DEVELOP THE
STANDARD TOLL WHICH WILL BE A
MUCH SHORTER ONE SO THE TOLL IT
TOOK A LONG TIME SO THAT THAT
WAS ONE OF THE DRAWBACKS.
BUT WE'VE ALREADY.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH THAT
THEY AND LICENSED LICENSEES AS
WELL AS THE L. P. A.'S.
AND GOT SOME OF THEIR FEEDBACK
FROM THE TOOL SO WE'VE ALREADY
REDUCE THE REGULATIONS ON THAT
TOLL FROM FIFTEEN HUNDRED TO
FIVE HUNDRED BASED ON THE SCOPE
AND SEVERITY OF ALL OF OF THE
REGULATIONS WHAT'S THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THAT.
THAT FINDING TO OCCUR LOOKING AT
PASSED STATUS SO WE'VE ALREADY
REDUCED IT DOWN SO WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE MUCH SHORTER -- AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO THE IMPEDIMENT
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION YOU KNOW
THERE'S LIMóN LIMITATIONS.
WITH OUR LEGACY SYSTEMS WERE
LOOKING TOWARDS GETTING ON A NEW --
I. T. SYSTEM BUT OUR OUR SYSTEMS
ARE VERY SLOW -- SO BUILDING
THAT INTO THAT SYSTEM THAT'S
GONNA BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
LIMITATION BUT WE'RE STILL YOU
KNOW GOING TO GO FORWARD WITH
THAT -- WORKING AROUND THOSE
CHALLENGES.
SO THE NEXT QUESTION WHAT ARE
THE AREAS OF CONTINUING
IMPROVEMENT IN THE COMPLAINT
PROCESSES.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
COMPLAINTS WE'VE HAD A BACKLOG
YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS
AND WE RECEIVE THIRTEEN
POSITIONS.
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS AND WERE ASKING FOR AN
EXTENSION OF FUNDING FOR ANOTHER
TWO YEARS FOR THOSE LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS WE DIVIDED THOSE THAT
BETWEEN ADULTS SENIOR CARE AND
AND CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THOSE.
THE RESIDENTIAL INSPECTIONS TAKE
MUCH LONGER THAN THE CHILD CARE
FACILITIES -- AND SO WE DIVIDED
THEM UP TO CONTINUE AT WE HAVE
REDUCE THE BACKLOG CONTINUALLY
OVER THE YEARS.
HOWEVER THE COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING -- OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS SO WE'VE BEEN KEEPING UP
WITH THE INCREASE COMPLAINTS AND
JUST WHITTLING AWAY AT THE
BACKLOG.
AND AS WELL AS KEEPING UP WITH
OUR INSPECTIONS.
WE'VE ALSO DIVIDE -- DEVELOP THE
STATE WIDE TRIAGE PROCESS SO
WHEN THE COMPLAINTS COME IN WE
HAVE PEACE OFFICER INVESTIGATORS
THAT WORK FOR US A SMALL CADRE
OF PEACE OFFICERS SO THEY DO OUR
PRIORITY ONES WITH CHURCH SEXUAL
ABUSE -- IT FOR ONE EXAMPLE AND
SO WE'VE DEVELOPED A TRIAGE
PROCESS SO IT'S EASY AND QUICK
AND IT'S A STANDARD ACROSS THE
STATE THAT.
THE COMPLAINT -- TRIAGE AND THEN
THEY'RE SENT EITHER TO THE THE
PEACE OFFICERS OR THEIR SENT
TOWARD L. P. A.'S.
THE MOST OF THEM GO OUT OF OUR
LPA IS THAT ARE THE THE NORMAL
ANALYSTS THAT DO THE INSPECTIONS
BUT IT'S MUCH FASTER IT'S MORE
EFFICIENT -- THE INVESTIGATORS
THE PEACE OFFICERS ARE TAKING ON
MORE WORK SO THAT THAT'S ONE WAY
THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED -- SOME OF
THE BACKLOG SO AND WE JUST
CONTINUE TO JUST LOOK FOR
EFFICIENCIES AS FAR AS WE STILL
WANT TO DO THOROUGH INSPECTIONS
WE DON'T WANT TO RUSH THROUGH
THESE INSPECTIONS SO OF THE
PRIMARY THE BACKLOG OR PRIORITY
THREE AND FORCE.
WHICH ARE -- THEY COULD BE COLD
FOOD OR IT COULD BE -- PAPER
ISSUES THEY'RE NOT HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES.
AND SO THE LAST QUESTION IS WHAT
IS THE FEEDBACK FROM DISTRICT
STAFF ON THE CHANGES ACROSS THE
CO.
SO THAT HAS BEEN -- IT'S A IT'S
A LONG CULTURE TO CHANGE THAT
THAT GOING FROM STRICTLY
ENFORCEMENT TO FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO KEEP THESE
FACILITIES AND COMPLIANCE -- AND
SO THEY VIEW THAT AS A POSITIVE
THEY THEY LIKE HAD TAKEN THE
TIME TO DO THAT AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE LICENSEE UNDERSTANDS
THE REGULATION THEY VIOLATED
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
WE FOUND.
IS WHEN WE WERE CITING THEM THEY
REALLY DIDN'T EVEN UNDERSTAND
THE THE RED REGULATION SO PART
OF THE TOOL IS.
THEY NEED TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
SHOW THEM THE REGULATION AND
EXPLAIN TO THEM AT THAT TIME.
WHERE THE VIOLATION OCCURRED SO
IT'S MORE OF A ADD A ADD
TRAINING AT THAT TIME AS WELL?
SO THAT.
PART OF THAT WAS THE POSITIVE
FROM THE STUFF -- THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CHANGES IN HOW WE WRITE
UP OUR REPORTS WITH PRINCIPLES
OF DOCUMENTATION THEY USED TO
WRITE FREE HAND AND SO THERE WAS
NO.
STANDARDIZATION THE THE REPORTS
ARE UP ON OUR WEBSITE WE HAVE
LIKE OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND HITS ON OUR WEBSITE A
MONTH SO.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
STANDARDIZATION SO THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE VIOLATION
WAS AND AND HAVE A SPECIFIC
FORMAT SO -- WE'VE EMBEDDED
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROCESSES
THROUGHOUT.
IS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CANCEL ON
WE IMPLEMENT THESE NEW CHANGES
THAT WE REALLY LOOK TO SEE IF
THEY'RE THEY'RE FOLLOWING THE
NEW GUIDELINES ON AND FOR THE
MOST PART THERE ARE THERE ARE --
THEIR SUPPORT OF OF THE OF THE
NEW PROCESS AS THEY SEE IT WAS
NEEDED IT WAS NEEDED IN THE
INDUSTRY -- AND IN IT WE JUST
INCREASED OUR TRAINING TEN FOLD --
ALL YEAR LONG WE'RE CONTINUALLY
FINDING NEW THINGS AND TRAINING
GIVEN THE BEST PRACTICES TO HELP
THE LICENSEES -- AND THEN LASTLY
WE HAVE -- YOU'LL SEE A PROPOSAL
COMING UP ON THE CHILD CARE
POSITIONS THE MONEY WAS BUILT
INTO THE BUDGET LAST YEAR AND SO
THERE'S GOING TO BE A OF A
PROPOSAL COMING FORWARD TO ASK
FOR THE POSITIONS -- TO DO THE
INSPECTIONS.
WELL WE TALKED ABOUT AT THE
BEGINNING IN TERMS OF
ENCOURAGING THEM TO EVERY EVERY
SINGLE YEAR FOR CHILD CARE.
YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONLY ONE THING I WANNA ADD IS I
HAVE TO HAND OUTS FOR YOU FOR
LATER THAT I HAD PASSED OUT ONE
IS ARMS INSPECTION PROCESS
PROJECT THAT.
IT'S THAT IT'S ON OUR WEBSITE
AND THEN OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN YEAR
IN REVIEW THAT KIND OF GIVES YOU
A SNAPSHOT OF SOME OF THE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE WHAT WE'VE
DONE OVER THE PAST YEAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE [inaudible]
HELLO.
BUT WE WE KNOW THAT USUALLY CCL
IS USUALLY PART OF THE FOSTER
CARE ISSUE -- IN THE SUB THREE
HEARINGS BUT WE DECIDED TO NEEDS
TO BE PUT AT THE FRONT --
BECAUSE YOU ARE TAKING CARE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE THE CHILDREN.
AND OUR SENIORS ARE ADULTS.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE INPUT AND
YOU'VE PROVIDED.
I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT GOING
ANNUALLY WITHI THINK THAT WITH
THE TWENTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION -- THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PUT INTO THE BUDGET TO WORK OUT
I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT.
NOW HAVING THE RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THIS
[inaudible]
A WONDERFUL.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS POINT.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME'S TONY
TICKET TELLEM A STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM.
A LOT OF OUR WORK IS IN SENIOR
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES.
NEARLY TO PRAISE THE WORK OF
COMMUNICATE LICENSING -- THEY'VE
DONE A FABULOUS JOB IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN KERR WAS
GETTING PRETTY BAD.
THE LEGISLATURE RESPONDED THE
PAST TEN DIFFERENT OF BILLS TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WERE GOING ON IN AND SEE
SEE A REALLY STEPPED UP TO THE
PLATE NAY BEEN.
BUSY EVER SINCE A LOT OF
REGULATORY PACKAGES TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE LAWS.
COMPLAINTS ARE ARE REALLY GOING
THROUGH THE ROOF UNFORTUNATELY --
AND THE INCREASED NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS WHICH IS GREAT --
THEY'VE DONE A FABULOUS JOB WITH
ALL THIS IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
TEAM.
THE LEAP FROM THE LEADERSHIP ON
DOWN THEY'RE VERY DEDICATED
SUPER COLLABORATIVE -- YOU CAN
TELL THEIR HEART IS IN THE WORK
AND IT REALLY SHOWS.
SO I'M JUST I I'M HERE JUST
GENERALLY ADVOCATE FOR MORE
RESOURCES I THINK.
NO L. P. A.'S ARE THE ARE THE
THE BLOOD.
OF THE INSPECTION SYSTEM WE NEED
MORE OF THEM IF IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE -- THE WEBSITE FOR
CONSUMERS WE DIDN'T HAVE ONE
FIVE YEARS AGO WE HAVE ONE NOW
BUT IT'S IT'S PRETTY LIMITED AND
AND BUILT ON AN ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM THAT COULD USE SOME
SERIOUS UPDATES.
BUT I'M JUST HERE TO SAY THAT I
THINK THE WORK LICENSING IS DONE
HAS BEEN GREAT.
AND WOULD LIKE TO EE MORE OF IT
THAT WE THINK THAT WE GET GREAT
VALUE FOR THE SPENDING -- AMONG
THE RICH THE RESIDENTS OF THESE
FACILITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INPUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
HE STOLE MY THUNDER.
IT IS A FABULOUS AT ITS FAMILIES
YOU'RE MORE FOUNDER YOU KNOW IT
IT IS GREAT TO HEAR BACK FROM
THE FIELD THAT -- ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS ARE OCCURRING MORE
AND MORE ACROSS THE STATE AND
THIS THIS THE EMPHASIS TOWARDS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TOWARDS
BASS PRACTICE AS OPPOSED TO A
PUNITIVE APPROACH FROM LICENSING
IN THAT THAT'S THE OMBUDSMAN
ROLLING WE DON'T TO MESS WITH
OUR OUR ROLE.
BUT WE ACTUALLY ARE ARE
EMBRACING THIS COLLECTION AND
SUPPORTING KEEPING THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF SO WE CAN
WHITTLE THAT BACKLOG OF
COMPLAINTS AWAY COMPLETELY AND
NEVER HAVE IT COME BACK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD ON ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE YOU HAVE AN ISSUE THAT YOU
HAD QUESTION YOU WANT TO ASK
BEFORE WE GO ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO YOUR CONSOLES BEEN SUCH A
GREAT JOB ON THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM.
ALL RIGHT THE WHAT WE TAKE ROLE.
BEFORE YOU WILL BEGIN TO COULD
JUST GIVE US JUST A MOMENT.
MISS RAY IS HERE MISTER BRAZIER.
MR MATHIS MR PATTISON PATTERSON
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MRS MISA RAMOS SORRY MISTER
RAMOS.
THIS RUBIO.
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
HAS [inaudible]
FOR MS ROMANS.
OKAY WHERE DO WE BEGIN IN THE
ORDER LISTED -- Là NAY.
YES STEPPED GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M LYNN A STOUT THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT AND
WITH ME TODAY IS J. SOMEONE
REALLY.
AREN'T HAPPY DIRECTOR.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A PANEL THAT
INCLUDES MANY OF OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES I THINK THAT'S WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR A LOT OF
VERY INTERESTING FEEDBACK AND
HEAR MORE ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS.
I CERTAINLY.
IS THAT BETTER OKAY GREAT I'M
BEFORE WE GET INTO THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM I
WANTED TO JUST BRIEFLY MENTIONED
THE DEPARTMENTS -- PRIMARILY
FUNDED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE RECEIVE ON A
ANNUAL BASIS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THOSE DOLLARS ARE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
THE LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND OUR
WEATHER'S ATION.
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN ADDITION
WE RECEIVE WE HAVE RECEIVED
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TWO MILLION IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS FOR FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS.
FOR OUR LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
THE PRIMARY MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS TO REDUCE POVERTY
IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. TO THOSE LIVING IN
POVERTY AND STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET.
WE ALLOCATE THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT FUNDING TO
A SIXTY A LOCAL AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THEY DELIVER ANNA POVERTY
SERVICES TO ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
STRENGTHEN THE ECONOMIC SECURITY
OF INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION ALONE
CAN CALIFORNIANS BENEFIT EVERY
YEAR FOR FOR OUR THIS PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE
DEPARTMENT FUNDS ENERGY
ASSISTANCE THAT HELP
CALIFORNIANS PAY THEIR UTILITY
BILLS PREVENT DISCONNECTIONS AND
IMPROVE THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THEIR
HOMES OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS -- RECEIVE PROGRAM OF
SERVICES EVERY YEAR.
WELL THE PRESIDENT'S PROPOSED
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET RECOMMENDS
ELIMINATING ALL OF ARE FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS CONGRESS HAS
HISTORICALLY SUPPORTED FUNDING.
THESE PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
LEVELS HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
STEADY -- THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
AND EVEN SOMETIMES INCREASING.
AS THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
IS ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
ANTI POVERTY TOOLS AVAILABLE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MADE INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
CLAIM THAT THE FEDERAL AND STATE
CREDITS.
A MAJOR PRIORITY FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THE DEPARTMENT HAS
LED A REDUCING POVERTY WORK
GROUP.
MADE UP OF PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE NON PROFITS COMMITTED TO
DEVELOPING STRATEGIES AND
COORDINATING THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME.
TAX CREDIT EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS.
AS PART OF THIS EFFORT CST HAS
PARTNERED WITH FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. TO ADMINISTER CAL EITC
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH.
GRANTS.
AS WELL AS THE NEW TAX
ASSISTANCE PREPARATION GRANTS.
FOR THIS TAX SEASON THE
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERED FIVE
MILLION IN GRANTS TO LOCAL AND
STATEWIDE NON PROFITS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONDUCT CALLIE
IDC EDUCATION AND OUTREACH.
AS WELL AS THE NEW PROGRAM THAT
WAS PROVIDING FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION FOR FREE TAX PREPARATION
ASSISTANCE.
THIS YEAR THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE OF 42% AND THE NUMBER
OF CALLIE IT SCRIPT CREDITS
ISSUED -- AS OF APRIL THIRTEENTH
AND THREE HUNDRED MILLION AND
CAL E. I. T. C. HAS BEEN CLAIMED
WHICH IS A 13% INCREASE.
NOW ON TO THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES ENERGY EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES.
SOLAR VOTER PHOTOVOLTAIC SYSTEMS
TO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF THE PROGRAM IS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY.
YOUR REDUCES ENERGY EXPENSES FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FREEING UP
LIMITED DISPOSABLE INCOME FOR
OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS THIS IS THE
ONLY PROGRAM OF ITS KIND IN
CALIFORNIA PROVIDING LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITH SOLAR PEAVEY.
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY UPGRADES
AT NO COST THERE'S FOUR
COMPONENTS TO THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM THE FIRST
EFFICIENCY AND SOLAR PEAVEY.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
AND OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS ERVED THROUGH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES AND OVER
FORTY TO HELP FORTY TWO HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS.
RECEIVED ROOFTOP SOLAR PEAVEY
SYSTEMS THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES RECEIVING THESE
SERVICES ARE MADE UP OF FIVE
REGIONS IN THE STATE.
AND FOR THE FIVE REGIONS FUNDING
HAS BEEN COMPLETELY EXPENDED THE
FIFTH REGION WILL BE FULLY
EXPENDED THIS MONTH -- I BELIEVE
YOU RECEIVED AN UPDATED FROM
WHAT WAS IN THE AGENDA SO
CURRENTLY -- IN OUR REGION FOR
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS REMAINING AND THAT WILL
BE COMPLETELY EXPENDED THIS
MONTH.
CONTINUATION OF STATEWIDE SINGLE
FAMILY AND SOLAR PEAVEY SERVICES
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS
DEPENDENT UPON FUTURE FUNDING.
THE SECOND COME A COMPONENT OF
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND INCENTIVES FOR
THE INSTALLATION OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND SOLAR
PEAVEY.
IN LOW INCOME MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS TO BENEFIT LOW INCOME
TENANTS WHILE ALSO HELPING TO
PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
A TOTAL OF FIFTY FOUR MILLION
HUSBAND ALLOCATE.
ALLOCATED AND TO DATE FIFTY
SEVEN HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
BEEN SERVED THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES THE FINAL FUNDING FOR
THE MULTI FROM FAMILY PROGRAM
WILL BE FULLY COMMITTED TO AND
ROLLED PROJECTS.
BY JUNE THE ENROLLMENT OF
ADDITIONAL A MULTI FAMILY
PROJECTS WILL BE CONTINGENT UPON
FUTURE FUNDING.
THE TWO NEW COMPONENTS OF THE
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM ARE THE COMMUNITY SOLAR
PILOT AND THE FARM WORKER
HOUSING THE COMMUNITY SOLAR
PILOT IS DESIGNED TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PARK DISSIPATE IN
EXISTING LOW INCOME SOLAR PEAVEY
PROGRAMS.
EITHER DUE TO A LACK OF HOME
OWNERSHIP OR INADEQUATE ROOFING
OR OTHER FACTORS. FOR THE PILOT
GREAT ALTERNATIVES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SANTA ROSA BAND
OF COOLEY INDIANS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY HAS BEEN AWARDED A LITTLE
OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS. TO
BENEFIT TRIBAL AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
INTEGER DISHING GRID IN
PARTNERSHIP TO THE PORT OF
RICHMOND WAS AWARDED A LITTLE
OVER TWO MILLION FOR A PROJECT
THAT WILL BENEFIT LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN RICHMOND'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN EXECUTED AND
AWARD THESE ARE IN THE INITIAL
STAGES OF IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROJECTS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE NEW SINGLE
FAMILY FARM WORKER HOUSING
COMPONENT.
WILL PROVIDE -- ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND SOLAR
PEAVEY SYSTEMS AND SINGLE FAMILY
FARM WORKER HOMES ACROSS TWELVE
COUNTIES WITH THE HIGHEST FARM
WORKER POPULATIONS WHICH INCLUDE
FRESNO MADERA MERCED MODERATE
SENATE JOAQUIN STANISLAUS
IMPERIAL KERN RIVER SIDE SANTA
BARBARA TO LAURIE AND VENTURA.
THESE TARGETED SERVICES WILL
IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
FARM WORKER HOUSING AND LOWER
ENERGY EXPENSES FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TEN AND A HALF
MILLION HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO
THE THIS COMPONENT ANOTHER FIVE
MILLION IN FUNDING OTHER THE
MULTI FAMILY PROGRAM HAS ALSO
BEEN CARVED OUT TO TARGET MULTI
FAMILY FARM WORKER HOUSING.
ON APRIL NINTH THE DEPARTMENT
ANNOUNCED THAT LUCK COOPER TEVA
HAD BEEN SELECTED AS THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE FARM WORKER
HOUSING COMPONENT.
FOLLOWING A COMPETITIVE TIVE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTED AN
EXTENSIVE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT EFFORT.
IN THE LEAD UP TO THE RELEASE OF
THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS THIS
INCLUDED HOLDING EVENTS AND
BAKERSFIELD FRESNO SALINAS IN
SACRAMENTO AND ENGAGING WITH
OVER FORTY STAKEHOLDER
ORGANIZATIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT DESIGNED THE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL TO PUT AN
EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
AND TIES TO LOCAL INCOME LOW
INCOME AND FARM WORKER
COMMUNITIES AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH LIKUD PARTY
ABOUT -- TO MAKE THIS NEW
PROGRAM COMPONENT OF SUCCESS THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET TEN
MILLION FOR THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
HOW THESE FUNDS WILL BE TARGETED --
WILL DEPEND ON THE FINAL
APPROPRIATION OF FUNDS AND ANY
PRIORITIES THAT WILL BE
IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
IN CLOSING I WANTED KNOWLEDGE
THE WORK OF ALL THE NONPROFIT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT
WE WORK WITH TO ALLEVIATE THE
CAUSES AND CONDITIONS OF POVERTY
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THERE ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED
TO STRENGTHENING THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU AND I'M SURE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE A
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION PALACE
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. TO THE
REST OF THE SHIRT WAS TO THE
REST OF THE PRESENTATIONS AND
UNLESS THERE IS A QUESTION.
THAT IS VERY PRESSING OKAY.
MADAM CHAIR -- AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS MEDICALLY SARAH AND I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LOCAL BUT IF YOUR CAMPESINA.
ECHO BUT IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY
ATION.
OF NATIONAL FARM WORKER
PROGRAM'S DESIGNATED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE EIGHTY TWO
ACCESS POINTS LOCATED IN ALL OF
THE THIRTY FOUR CALIFORNIA'S
MOST SIGNIFICANT AGRICULTURAL
COUNTIES.
WE SERVE OR ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE A
YEAR AND OVER FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND OF THESE ARE
FARMWORKERS.
WE HAVE BEEN AT ACTIVELY SEEKING
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS THE SERVER
THE FARM WORKER COMMUNITIES FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
OUR STATE HAS ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED FALL SOME FARMWORKERS.
AND 18% OF DEALT WITH OWN HOME.
IN SPITE OUR USUAL FOR RECALL
SCHOOLS TO HAVE EXTENDED FAMILY
LIVING WITH HIM.
SO THE CONSUMPTION PER UNIT
APOSTLE IS MUCH GREATER.
EVERY YEAR WE HAVE SOUGHT OF
FUNDING TO OFFER EXTENSIVE
WHETHER INFLATION.
APPLIANCE REPLACEMENT AND SOLAR
PANEL INSTALLATION FOR
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE ENERGY
CONSUMPTION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN X.
MENTIONED BEFORE LOCAL BUT IF
YOU I RECEIVED FUNDING FROM CAP
AND TRADE THROUGH THE LANGUAGE
PROGRAM -- ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMUTER SERVICES IN DEVELOPMENT
WE SERVE THE REGION FIVE WHICH
INCLUDED FIVE COUNTIES.
SOME OF THESE COMPANIES HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FARM WORKER
POPULATIONS.
IN CONNIE FLIGHT RIVERSIDE AND
IMPERIAL ENERGY IS A HUGE
EXPENSE DUE TO EXTREMELY HOT
WEATHER.
WE WERE ABLE TO SERVE OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED HOMES AND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX OF THESE
WERE.
INSTALLED SOLAR PANELS.
THE POPULATION WE SERVE HALF AN
INCOME THAT RANGES FROM TEN TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
OUR GOAL IS TWO FOLD.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS OBVIOUSLY
TO REDUCE THE CARBON FOOTPRINT.
BUT INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ALSO IS
RAISING THEIR DISPOSABLE INCOME
THIS IS HUGE FOR OUR PEOPLE --
AND THAT'S WHERE WE MY HARD IS
IT IS THAT WITH THIS PROGRAM --
IN FACT WHEN WE READ TO YOU.
BOUGHT FOR THIS MORNING FOR THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE.
QUOTE THE PROGRAM HAS HELPED MY
FAMILY AND HOME AMANDA SO.
THE COST OF MY ELECTRIC BILL IN
THE SUMMERS USED TO BE ALMOST
FIVE HUNDRED A MONTH.
BY NOW IRON PAYING LESS THAN
TWENTY DOLLARS SOME I'VE.
THAT'S GREAT WHEN I WAS A KID WE
USED TO PAY A MERCHANT CALEXICO
PART PERFECT FOUNDER DOLLARS
MONTH.
SECOND QUOTE.
IT IS LOWER MY GOOD ACTORS TO
THE BILL MY FIRST BILL WAS TWO
DOLLARS AND FORTY FOUR CENTS.
IN UPCOMING BAIL IS FOUR DOLLARS
AND FORTY FOUR CENTS.
I WISH I WOULD HAVE SIGNED UP
SOONER.
ANOTHER ONE MY ELECTRIC BILL
USED TO BE SEVENTY FIVE TO
EIGHTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
AROUND JANUARY BUT THIS MONTH
ONLY PAID FIVE DOLLARS.
AND THIS IS REALLY WHAT THE
PROGRAMS ON THE BOTTOM BUT IT
SHOULD BE ALL ABOUT.
BESIDES REDUCING THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
SERVICES DEVELOPMENT RECENTLY
AWARDED LOOK OVER AT THE WHITE
WAS SMASHED BY THE DIRECTOR.
OF A GRANT. TO SERVE TWELVE
CONTESTS IN NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS OUR HOPE THE FUTURE
CAPTAIN FREE FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED FOR FARMWORKERS AND
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THE CURRICULA IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE AND I MYSELF WILL
ADVOCATE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
AND THE EXPANSION TO FOR
FARMWORKERS AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE FACTORY IN
ALL.
WE SPENDING BILLIONS TO REDUCE.
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST NOT FORGET.
OUR POOR PEOPLE THE WORKING POOR.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO BE GREEN
UNLESS WE INTERVENE AND HELP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLACE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ANNA AND YOUR BROOKS I'M THE
WEST COAST DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY.
AND WE'RE A NONPROFIT TECHNICAL
SERVICES AND TRAINING
ORGANIZATION THAT'S DEDICATED TO
ACHIEVING ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
BUILDINGS IN ORDER TO FOSTER AND
MAINTAIN AFFORDABLE AND HEALTHY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE STATEWIDE
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM FOR MULTI FAMILY AND IN
THAT ROLE WE PROVIDE ALL OF THE
TECHNICAL AND PROJECT MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE NEEDED BY PROPERTY
OWNERS.
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT DEEP
ENERGY RETROFIT PROJECTS --
WE'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING LOW
INCOME MULTI FAMILY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLE.
ENERGY PROGRAMS UP FOR A VARIETY
OF STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES UTILITIES SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND I CAN
DEFINITIVELY SAY.
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS THE MOST
INNOVATIVE AND IMPACTFUL -- THE
WE'VE EVER BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH.
RESIDENTS OF MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN AN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT POPULATION TO SERVE
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
INCLUDING THE INHERENT SPLIT
INCENTIVE THAT EXIST BETWEEN
PROPERTY OWNERS TO PAY FOR AND
PURCHASE THE ENERGY CONSUMING
EQUIPMENT IN THE BUILDING AND
THE TENANTS ARE TYPICALLY PAY
FOR THE UTILITY BILLS -- OTHER
CHALLENGES INCLUDE THE JUST THE
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES TRYING TO
GET INTO EVERY.
UNIT OF A MULTI FAMILY BUILDING
IN ONE PASS IN ONE OF A KIND OF
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT -- THE
COORDINATION OF THE VARIOUS
TRADES AND CONTRACTORS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO PERFORM THESE
COMPREHENSIVE RETROFITS AND JUST
THE LIMITED BUDGETS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDERS -- MANY OF THESE
PROPERTIES OPERATE ON VERY VERY
THIN -- MARGINS AND AND AND WITH
VERY RESTRICTED OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACCESS THAT -- SO THOSE ARE JUST
A FEW OF THE CHALLENGES AND THE
LIVE AT MULTI FAMILY PROGRAM HAS
ADDRESSED MANY OF THESE
CHALLENGES IN VERY UNPRECEDENTED
WAYS.
IT'S THE FIRST MULTI FAMILY
PROGRAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO BREAK DOWN THE
KIND OF ARTIFICIAL SILOS THAT IF
THE THAT EXIST BETWEEN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND SOLAR AND IS ABLE
TO DELIVER BOTH OF THOSE
RESOURCES TO THESE PROJECTS --
IN A SINGLE KIND OF DELIVERY
MODEL AND A SINGLE -- FOR TO
REFUND SINGLE FUNDING SOURCE.
IT WAS ALSO THE FIRST MULTI
FAMILY PROGRAM IN THE STATE TO
DEVELOP A MEANS OF OF REALLY
INCENTIVIZING AND AND DRIVING
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION AND D.
CARBONIZATION PROJECTS.
IT'S THE ONLY MULTI FAMILY PER
LOW INCOME PROGRAM THAT'S ABLE
TO SERVE BOTH DEED RESTRICTED
REGULATED AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
WELL AS NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
UNREGULATED AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AND IT PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
INCLUDING A FARM WORKER HOUSING
ELDERLY POPULATIONS AND FORMALLY
HOMELESS.
FACILITIES THAT ARE DESIGNED FOR
FORMALLY HOMELESS.
SO THERE.
THERE ARE FEW USERS THE FEW OF
THE SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF THE LANDMARK PROGRAM
UNFORTUNATELY.
DESPITE ITS SUCCESS AND THE
OVERWHELMING DEMAND FOR THE
PROGRAM.
IT'S STILL REMAINS FAIRLY UNDER
FUNDED AND VERY UNPREDICTABLY
FUNDED -- AND AS A RESULT WE
HAVE A WAITING LIST THAT
REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND LOW INCOME RESIDENTS IN
OVER A THOUSAND BUILDINGS
CURRENTLY.
THIS IS IT THE THE MULTI FAMILY
PROGRAM IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
PROGRAM BUT THE ONES THAT
DELIVER MULTIPLE BENEFITS TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESS.
POVERTY HEALTH HOUSING COSTS
RESILIENCE AND CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION THAT REQUIRE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABLE AND PREDICTABLE
FUNDING.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LOUISE
SPONSORS AND I'M THE CEO OF
COMMUNITY RESOURCE PROJECT A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED IN
SACRAMENTO -- AND FOR FORTY SIX
YEARS WE PROVIDED MUCH NEEDED A
POVERTY INTERVENTION SERVICES TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ARE WE PROVIDE SERVICES IN MORE
THAN TEN LANGUAGES.
A AND TO MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND CLIENTS ANNUALLY OF
THROUGH BOTH OUR HEALTH AND
ENERGY DIVISIONS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE ARE
REGIONAL MINISTER TO FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE SIR
SEVEN COUNTIES.
UNDER THE LIVE WITH PROGRAM.
AND WE DELIVERED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND SOLAR
PEAVEY TO OVER FOUR HUNDRED A
LOW INCOME HOMES MAKING THEM
MORE HEALTHY AND COMFORTABLE --
WE WERE ALSO BECAUSE WE ARE A
LIE HE PROVIDER AND WEATHER'S
ATION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
PROVIDER WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS. TO THESE
HOMEOWNERS OR RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS -- OVER THE PAST
FORTY YEARS WE'VE HAD OF GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF SERVING LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE CAN.
INSTALL THESE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
MEASURES.
AND TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
THOSE MEASURES THAT COULD BE
INSTALLED IN OUR HOMES.
AND WE'VE ALSO WORKED WITH --
RENTAL A MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS
AS WELL.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THE
TYPE OF HOUSING THAT WE
ENCOUNTER WHEN.
WHEN WE'RE TRYING -- TO INSTALL
THESE DIFFERENT.
MEASURES AND JUST BECAUSE
CLIENTS ARE LOW INCOME DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THEY CAN'T RECEIVE THE
SAME QUALITY OF SERVICE THAT
EVERYONE ELSE CAN -- A OBTAIN.
WE'VE WE'VE TRAINED OUR PARTNERS
THAT HAVE WORKED WITH US TO
ENSURE THAT THE DELIVERY OF
THESE.
MEASURES AND SERVICES ARE OF A
HIGH STANDARD WE'VE ALSO
MONITORED ARE PARTNERED AGENCIES
TO ENSURE THAT THE THE WORK PLAN
THAT TO A THAT WE DEVELOPED WAS
ACHIEVING THE OUTCOMES OF THE OF
THE PROGRAM.
AND ALSO THE CONTRACT -- TIME
PERIOD. ONE ONE RECOMMENDATION
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE IS
THAT -- IS WE NEED CONTINUED
FUNDING -- WHEN THE LIGHT WHAT
PROGRAM COMPLETE WE COMPLETED
THE PROGRAM IN MAY HAVE?
TWENTY EIGHTEEN C. R. P. HAD TO
CEASE WORKING ON ADDITIONAL
HOMES.
FROM WE KNOW THAT IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THAT REGION ALONE
THERE ARE.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES ARE COULD BENEFIT
FROM CONTINUED FUNDING IF THAT
WAS AVAILABLE.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO A TO A
HAVE BEEN THAT -- YOU KNOW OF
DEVELOP IN ITS.
IN THE FUTURE.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE OF ONE OF OUR
SUCCESS STORIES -- WE HAVE
PHILLIP LANNY SEES A FIFTY TWO
YEAR OLD DISABLED.
MAN.
HE LIVES IN A MOBILE HOME FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS.
HE'S WE'LL BERIT WE'LL.
OUT CHAIR BOUND IN AND LIVES
ALONE SO MAINTAINING HIS MOBILE
HOME IS VERY DIFFICULT.
IS WINDOWS WERE IN SUCH DAMAGE
AND SO WE REPLACE TEN OF HIS
WINDOWS MAKING IT MORE
COMFORTABLE FOR HIS.
LIVING CONDITIONS WE ALSO
REPLACES WATER HEATER WE PLACES
HEATING AND AIR CONDITIONING
UNIT WITH NEW ONES.
AND ARE ALSO PROVIDED A UTILITY
A UTILITY ASSISTANCE PAYMENT SO
HE COULD DO -- CONTINUE -- WITH
HIS HIS LIVING CONDITIONS SO
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM.
HE WOULDN'T HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
HAVING A HEATER.
DURING THE WINTERTIME AND SO
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF SERVICES
THAT MANY PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PEOPLE LIKE THAT THE JOE DIRT
THAT CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE SUPPORT WROTE APARTMENT A
FINANCE NOTHING THAT HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE [inaudible]
HELLO.
NOTHING TO ADD [inaudible]
WONDERFUL.
WHAT WE OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ROBERT CASTANEDA AND
I AM A MEMBER OF THE LOW INCOME
OVERSIGHT BOARD THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION --
WANTED DRESSES COMMITTEE IN
CONNECTION WITH THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE OVERSEE WHICH ARE LOW
INCOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE. ONE IS
CARE -- WHICH IS A DIRECT RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TARGETING
INCOME QUALIFY THE OTHER IS HE
SAID.
WHICH IS ENERGY SAVINGS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF LIGHT WHERE
BECAUSE IT IS A VERY UNIQUE
PROGRAM IT COMPLEMENTS WHAT WE
DO WITH EASE A VERY WELL.
BUT IT GOES INTO AREAS OF
SERVICE THE OESA IS VERY LIMITED.
IN OTHER WORDS IT IT STANDS
GREATER LEVELS OF WEATHERIZATION
IT ALSO PROVIDES A SOLAR
COMPONENT WHICH THE UTILITY
PROGRAMS DO NOT.
SO I THINK THAT REALLY WHAT WE
WANT TO SAY IS IS THAT THE CPU
SEE WE REALLY USE Y. WEAPON THAT
DISCUSSION OF LIGHT WEAPON THE
WE NEED TO GROW THIS PROGRAM
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
IS REALLY A FOUR RUNNER FOR WHAT
WE NEED TO DO WITH LOW INCOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE.
SO I RISE IN SUPPORT OF NOT ONLY
LIVE WEB BUT CST.
IN CONNECTION WITH ITS CONTINUED
PERFORMANCE IN CONNECTION WITH
THE LOGIN WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD HUMBLY REQUEST THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM A
CONNECTION WITH NOT ONLY THE
EXISTING BUDGET BUT ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ
ADDIS ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL COAST
ENERGY SERVICES WERE ACTUALLY
FRUSTRATED PARTY WHEN IT COMES
TO SEE ES DE AS YOUR STAFF.
ANALYSIS NOTES THERE'S BEEN AN
ISSUE WITH THE FUNDING FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE COMING OUT OF CST
WHEN THEY MADE A MAJOR CHANGE TO
THE POLICY WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT.
AFTER SOME FRUSTRATION WE'VE
EVEN COME TO THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE PAST WE ASK FOR CHANGE AND
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED SOME
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE THEY WOULD
SUGGEST THE AGENCY WHEN IT.
SAYS PRESS ANY MORE FUTURE MONEY
OUT YOU WOULD TRY TO WORK WITH
TRADITIONAL LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY.
EVIDENCE OF THAT.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR IF THE
AGENCIES TRYING TO DO WITH FARM
WORKER HOUSING.
IN MULTI UNIT HOUSING WE ARE
SUPER SUPPORTIVE AND IF
TRADITIONAL LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS CAN'T DO THAT IT IS
FINE TAKE SOME FUNDING TO GO DO
THAT.
INSTEAD WITH THE AGENCIES DOWN
IS A RIP THEM THE MONEY AWAY
FROM THE LOCAL THE TRADITIONAL
LOCAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND THAT NO LONGER ALLOWS US TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING AND USE
OUR EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE ON
THE GROUND SO WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU HOLD THIS FUNDING OR PUT IN
SOME KIND OF PROVISION TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
SOME FUNDING IS GOING TO GO TO
LOCAL SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
LEVERAGING FEDERAL FUNDING THANK
YOU.
EXCELLENT POINT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MILES
MILLER WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
NRDC SUPPORTS CONTINUED FUNDING
OF THE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN --
CRITICAL AND IMMENSELY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM FOR
MAINTAINING HEALTHY AFFORDABLE
HOMES FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
THE WEATHER IS ASIAN AND SOLAR
INSTALLATIONS -- OVER FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS OFTEN FACING
DISPROPORTIONATE AND YOU BURDENS.
AND SETTLED HIGH NEED HIGH
ENERGY BILLS THEY CANNOT AFFORD.
LOGAN HOUSEHOLDS SPEND UP 215%
OF THEIR INCOME ON ENERGY ALONE
AND UP TO THREE TIMES AS MUCH OF
THEIR INCOME ON ENERGY AS OTHER
HOUSEHOLDS.
THE THREE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS LIVING MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENTS FACE ADDITIONAL
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS.
THE RESULT IN EVEN GREATER
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY SERVICES AND FURTHER
IMPROVEMENTS TO HOUSEHOLD HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
THE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE LOW INCOME ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION FOR EXPANDING EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SERVICES. TO LOW INCOME AND
MULTI FAMILY HOUSEHOLDS
ACHIEVING ON AVERAGE 30%
REDUCTIONS IN HOUSEHOLD ENERGY
BILLS.
AND 40% REDUCTIONS IN ENERGY
USAGE THERE IS COMPREHENSIVE
WHOLE BUILDING APPROACH.
THE PROGRAM FILLS A CRITICAL GAP
IN CLEAN ENERGY BILL SERVICES TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
SUPPORT HOUSING AND ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA'S.
LOWEST INCOME RESIDENTS IN MULTI
FAMILY RENTAL HOUSING.
ACCORDINGLY WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT CONTINUED
AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM TO ENSURE ITS ABLE TO
CONTINUE SERVING THE NEEDS OF
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NORTHERN SUPPORT ANY IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OPPOSE.
ALL RIGHT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MISS FRAZIER.
HOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE PROGRAM
AND THE VAST AMOUNT OF --
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU TRIED TO
HELP.
BACK IN THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION -- THERE WAS THE
DEMISE OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
ID DE POPULATION.
AND WE RE -- A MAJORITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN A GROUP ON STRUCK
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY EFFORT TO
CREATE ANY KIND OF PROGRAM THAT
YOU COULD ACTUALLY AUGMENT THESE
GROUP HOMES WITH THIS SOLAR
PROCESS OR WHATEVER WERE MORE
MONEY.
THE MOST MONEY SAVINGS COULD
ACTUALLY BE UTILIZED IN.
THE TRAINING OF THESE ENVISIONED
END OF THE ID POPULATION.
OF AND ALSO IN IN HELPING.
EACH ONE OF YOU.
IN THE INTEGRATED WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
COMPONENT -- BECAUSE HE'S A LOT
OF JOBS THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
CAN ACTUALLY ACQUIRING DO.
WITH HIGH LEVELS OF PROFICIENCY.
BUT I'M I'M THINKING THAT YOU
KNOW.
WE CREATED A A COST.
BY RELOCATING THEM WE THOUGHT WE
WERE SAVING MONEY BUT IF WE WERE
ABLE TO USE THIS PROGRAM ALSO
BECAUSE THEY ARE LOW INCOME OR
NO INCOME.
THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY AGAIN
THEN UTILIZE A SAVINGS FOR
TRAINING.
AND AND AND KIND OF CROSS HYBRID
MODEL OF YOU CROSS UTILIZATION.
I JUST I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT
OUT THERE.
MR WITH.
YEAH JUST CURIOUS -- HOW DO YOU
DECIDE WHICH LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES YOU GO INTO?
IS THAT BASED ON GREENHOUSE GONE
ON THE GAC FUND AND THE ENVIRO
SCAN.
SO IS BASED ON THE VIRUS CAM.
SO YOU DON'T GO IN ANY MY
COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW GOING TO SOME OF THE
POOREST COMMUNITIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORIA BECAUSE WE DON'T
[inaudible]
HIT.
THE BENCH MARKS ON THE VIRUS
SCAN BECAUSE WE HAVE CLEAN AIR
AND WE HAVE CLEAN WATER WE GOT A
LOT OF POOR PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR ME.
THE HUGE PROBLEM FOR ME.
SPECIFICALLY THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM AND HOW
IT'S CURRENTLY IS ADMINISTERED
IT IS BASED ON THE CALAVERAS
GREEN I THINK IT'S WRONG QUITE
FRANKLY I GOT SOME REALLY POOR
PEOPLE.
IN REALLY AND AND REALLY
DIFFICULT CLIMB METS AND THEY
CAN'T GET ACCESS TO THIS I THINK
IT'S UNFAIR WE DO HAVE THE LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT'S FEDERALLY FUNDED
AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
SO WE DO HAVE A LOCAL ENERGY
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
JUST WITH A DIFFERENT FUND
SOURCE BUT I I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN.
AND IF I CAN ADD -- AS A
DIRECTOR STOP MENTION IN THEIR
REMARKS THAT WE RECEIVED TWO
HUNDRED TWO MILLION DOLLARS --
FROM THE GIRAFFE A THE FUN Là
WOULD SINCE -- FISCAL YEAR
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND THE EARLY
APPROPRIATIONS WERE LIMITED --
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
EXCLUSIVELY HOWEVER SOME OF THE
MORE RECENT -- APPROPRIATIONS
DID PUT A ALLOW FOR CERTAIN A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF OF
INVESTMENTS TO BE MADE OUTSIDE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES AND FOCUS
MORE ON LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
AND SO WE UNDERSTAND YOU MIGHT
COMMUNITIES QUITE FRANKLY --
DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
WATER BY PROJECTS BUT WE DON'T
QUALIFY FOR THE DECISION THE
FUNDING THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
BASED ON THE G. G. R. F. AND I
THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE HERE THAT'S ONE REASON
YOU HEAR MEMBERS IN THIS.
IN THIS IN THIS HOUSE TALK ABOUT
THE ENVIRO SCANNED I THINK IT'S
IT'S VERY UNFAIR -- TO
COMMUNITIES AND RURAL RURAL
AREAS THE STATE WHERE THE AIR
QUALITY MIGHT BE GOOD.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T CHECK ALL
FOURTEEN BOXES.
AND AND I I REPRESENT SOME OF
THE PORTS ON THE POOREST THE THE
THE LOOK AT THE MISTER AS AS
MISTER MATHIS OVER THEIR NIGHT
MEANT MISTER IS ANY BRING UP A
GREAT POINT I THINK THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING A LOT OF US
AGREE ON THAT WE COULD LOOK AT
AS FAR.
AS LANGUAGE MOVING FORWARD YEAH
I JUST THINK IT NEEDS TO BE MORE
EQUITABLE I MEAN.
NOT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES -- THE
COMMISSION OF MINE AND I'LL SHOW
YOU AND THEN.
BUT IN AGAIN THERE'S BEEN SO
MANY FAT FACETS OF CALAVERAS
SCREEN THAT WE HAVEN'T.
AND THE BAY AREA OF NOT AGREED
THAT IS AN EQUITABLE KIND OF
SHARING OF OF PROCESS.
WE THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
ANOTHER FORM OF FORMULA OR
METHOD OF OF ALLOCATION.
BASED ON NEEDNOT ON PERCEIVED
HE ALL RIGHT MOVE THERE'S ANY
NOTHING ELSE FROM THE DíAS --
GO AHEAD IN -- CLOSE UP ON THIS
ISSUE AND MOVED TO ISSUE THREE
AND I'LL PASSED THE GAVEL
REMOVED OR NOT LOOK AT HER AND
WE BACK TO THE CHURCH THE
NOT A
LIKE [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
ON THAT ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO I KNOW THAT YOU WALDRON
EXCUSE [inaudible]
HELLO YEAH YEAH.
I TRY TO GET BACK QUICKLY BUT
NOT QUICK ENOUGH.
I DO WANT TO DO THE L. CST --
ALL RIGHT I I DID WANT YOU TO
DESCRIBE IT A BIT MORE DETAIL
HOW YOUR ASSURING THAT THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
DO HAVE COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE.
ONE THING WE ARE VERY -- AWARE
OF IS THE FACT THAT WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO HAVE
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT AND
ENSURING THAT WERE HAVING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
SO WITH THE MOST RECENT REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL WE HELD --
COMPREHENSIVE OF A STAKEHOLDER
EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
WERE IN FRESNO WE GOT A REQUEST
TO DO A STAKEHOLDER EVENT IN
SALINAS WE WENT TO SALINAS THERE
WAS AT LEAST -- I THINK FORTY
DIFFERENT MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTED.
WE DID INITIALLY A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE GETTING AS MUCH
FEEDBACK AS WE POSSIBLY COULD AS
WE LOOKED AT MAKING SURE THAT
THE COMMUNITY TIES WHICH IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL AND IMPORTANT.
WAS BEING ACKNOWLEDGED AND SO WE
TOOK THE INFORMATION BACK WE
HELD WEBINARS AND RESPONDED TO
THE QUESTIONS IN THE INQUIRIES
THAT WE GOT FROM THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS.
I'M AND WE ALSO -- WERE WERE
VERY COGNIZANT ESPECIALLY THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE HAVE
DONE A REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL
AFTER A SB EIGHTY NINE WHICH HAD
A THE VERY SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
AND FOR THIS REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL BECAUSE OF THE
POPULATION OF FARM WORKER
HOUSING WE REALLY FELT THAT THAT
WAS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF WHAT
WE WERE TARGETING AS WELL AS THE
LOW INCOME IN GENERAL.
AND AS WELL AS THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY EXPERIENCE SO I I
THINK THAT THE OF OUR OF P. THE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE AND DID TAKE IN
THAT FEEDBACK -- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME THAT STILL ARE
NOT AND WE HAVE A CONTRACTOR THE
STILL IS NOT HAPPY ABOUT THE
ULTIMATE OUTCOME BUT I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT WAS VERY TRANSPARENT.
AND AND HAD OF MULTIPLE FORMS
AND AND MAYBE OTHERS -- WITH
REGARD TO THOSE THAT WERE ON THE
RECEIVING END OF EVERYTHING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HEAD FROM THE
STAKEHOLDER PERSPECTIVE MIGHT BE
BETTER TO FILL IN SOME
INFORMATION IF THEY HAVEN'T LEFT.
BUT I THINK I THINK -- MARCO
COULD ALSO SPEAKS ABOUT IT MIGHT
BE HELPFUL TO HEAR FROM SOMEBODY
WHO WAS ON THE RECEIVING END OF
OUR EFFORTS AROUND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT BEFORE YOU LEAVE AND
I LAST MARK ON JUST A MOMENTYES
IT.
IS IS THERE A NEED FOR CAPACITY
BUILDING.
SO THAT WE'RE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
SO THAT THE COMMUNITY TIES ARE
THERE -- WHEN WE WHEN WE DO IT?
WHEN WE DO ISSUE THE CONTRACTS?
ONE SPEAKS OUT RIGHT -- SO THAT
THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL --
INCLUDED -- REQUIREMENTS WHERE
PROPOSES HAVE TO SPECIFY THEIR
THE REGION'S THE REGIONAL AREAS
THAT THEY WERE INTENDING TO
SERVE -- SUBSTANTIATE THAT THEY
HAVE A PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN
THOSE AREAS AS WELL AS TO
ELABORATE ON THEIR SERVICE
CONNECTION TO THOSE AREAS
BECAUSE THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING PHYSICALLY IN THE
AREA AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
SERVICE THE AREA ABSOLUTELY --
SO IN IN ADDITION THE THE ART
PIECE SCORED HIS SCORING RUBRIC
THAT EMPHASIZE -- HIGHER POINTS
TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT MET THOSE
TWO KEY CRITERIA -- BUT TO
SPECIFIC QUESTION ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE PROGRAM DOES
FACE.
IS THAT YOU KNOW THE HAVING SOME --
IT THE COTTON WITH THE IN
FINDING -- BECAUSE THESE PUT
THESE EFFORTS THAT WE UNDERTAKE
FOR EACH.
PROGRAM CYCLE -- ARC WE ARE
ASKING A LOT OF OUR CONTRACTORS
NOT ONLY ARE WE ASKING THEM TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM BUT WE
ALSO ARE ASKING THEM TO BE
INNOVATIVE IN THE LOOK AT
WRAPAROUND SERVICES OR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPING UP BETWEEN THESE THAT.
CAN NIGHT THAT CAN COMPLEMENT
THE THE CORE OBJECTIVES OF
REDUCING GHG AS WELL AS REDUCING
THE ENERGY BILLS FOR LOW INCOME.
AND THOSE STRATEGIES SOMETIMES A
LIMITED BECAUSE THE FUNDING IS
SHORT TERM OR WE CAN'T SUSTAIN
THE THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS
BEEN ASSEMBLED AT EACH A PROGRAM
CYCLE.
AND SO THE THING IS WHAT YOU
WERE HEARING FROM SOME OF THE
MINISTRY THERE IS -- WAS THAT
POINT OF ENSURING THAT THERE'S
LONG TERM FINDING AND THAT WE
CAN SUSTAIN SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS LOCALLY.
THAT IN THE GUIDANCE THAT WAS
LISTED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
ON COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE IT
TALKED ABOUT REGIONAL.
AS OPPOSED TO MORE SPECIFIC --
WHY WHAT WAS WIDE THAT THAT TERM --
WHY WAS THAT TERM USED SO THE
TERM -- SO FOR THE FARM WORKER
PROGRAM WE IDENTIFIED THE TWELVE
COUNTIES THE HAD THE HIGHS
FORMER CO POPULATION.
BUT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAMMERS
APPROXIMATE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS -- TO TO
EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT EFFECTIVE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM SO
WE WEEK ESTABLISHED TO SERVICE
REGION'S WITH SIX COUNTIES EACH
AND THEN -- WE ASKED PROPOSES TO
DETAIL THEIR PLANS FOR HOW THEY
WERE INTENDING TO MEETALL THE
REQUIREMENTS AND ESTABLISH A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN SERVING.
THE INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES THAT
MAKE UP EACH REGION AREA SO --
THAT'S BASICALLY HOW THE PROGRAM
IS STRUCTURED SO THAT YOU NICELY
ENCOMPASSES -- AN ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT -- SERVICES
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU[inaudible]
MR ETCETERA -- QUESTION.
THERE IS NEW STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT HAVING A TIES
TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS DOING TO BUY
ENSURE THAT -- THOSE WHO WERE
CONTRACTED DID HAVE COMMUNITY
TIES AND BECAUSE YOU WERE ON THE
RECEIVING AND TO HOW HOW WAS
THAT.
QUESTION ELSTOW WAS THAT -- HOW
IMPORTANT WAS THAT IN YOU?
APPLYING FOR AND RECEIVING THIS.
THE TWO OF YOU FOR EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT FITS US.
EVEN THE FACT THAT WE ARE AN
ASSOCIATION THAT SPREAD OUT
THROUGH THIRTY FOUR PORT
COUNTIES WITH OFFICES ACTUALLY
WITH EIGHTY TWO ACCESS POINT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PROGRAM WHERE.
ARE YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY THE
PEOPLE THE QUALIFIED BY CENSUS
TRACKS.
OKAY SO YOU MIGHT HAVE AN AREA
WITH FEW CENSUS TRACKS SO YOU
COMBINED INTO OUR REGION.
NOW YOU HAVE THE QUANTITY THAT
MAKES IT A LOT MORE FEASIBLE
ECONOMICALLY AND USE ECONOMIC.
CONSCIOUS SCALE TO DO THAT SO
THE REGIONAL MADE A LOT OF SENSE
TO US AND WE HAVE BEEN IN HAVE
YOU KNOW OFFICE SYSTEM A LOT OF
IS THAT LITTLE TINY SMALL TOWNS.
BROUGHT.
IT ALL ALL THE WAY TO IMPERIAL
VALLEY TO CALEXICO.
AND PEOPLE KNOW US WE WERE THERE
FOR FIFTY YEARS THAT WE HAVE
SOME TRUST.
AND THAT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IN SERVING THIS
COMMUNITIES TODAY.
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
SCAMS.
IT ALL WITH SOLAR PANEL
INSTALLATIONS THAT HAVE GONE OUT
IN FACT WE RUN INTO THAT.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
MADAM CHAIR.
WELL THEY ALL CAME BACK I HAD
MORE QUESTIONS ON GETTING
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE I DO WANT TO WELCOME THE
NEW DIRECTOR THANK YOU -- ALL
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN UNIQUE WHEN
YOU'D LIKE AFTERNOON THAT DAY
BECAUSE WE'RE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES -- BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- FOR
THE CHOPPER PROGRAMS INCREASE
FUNDING [inaudible]
THIS INITIATIVE SEARCH THREE
MAJOR PURPOSES FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION -- AS THE GOVERNOR
MENTIONED ONE OF HIS MAJOR
PARTIES IS -- THIS BATTLE AND
AND CHALLENGE AGAINST POVERTY
WITH CALIFORNIA.
THE CHARLES FOR PROGRAM.
FLEX OVER TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO BILLION OF THAT
GOES TOWARDS THE FAMILIES THAT
WE SERVE.
OF THE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES THAT
THIS PARTICULAR FUNDING IS GOING
TOWARDS -- HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST POVERTY RATES IN THE
STATE A AN AVERAGE OF FIFTEEN
POINT 1% -- AS OPPOSED -- TO AND
SOME AS HIGH AS 21% IN FRESNO
KERN MADERA -- THE SECOND PIECE
OF THIS FUNDING THAT I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT -- TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THIS NEED TO
IMPROVE SELF SUFFICIENCY MUCH
THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE --
CHILD SUPPORT IS A MAJOR
COMPONENT OF MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AS INCOME ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
SERVICES IN THESE TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR ARE ARE
BROUGHT UP TO THE SAME STAND
LEVEL OF SUPPORT THAT.
AND THE REST OF THE STATE IS
RECEIVING HAVE THE LAST PIECES
ABOUT FINDING A QUALITY THERE'S
BIG DISPARITY IN A BIG GAP
BETWEEN THE LOS FUND COUNTIES IN
HIGH SPENDING COUNTIES IN THE
EFFORT TO DELIVER CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
THE TWENTY ONE IDENTIFIED HERE --
ON AVERAGE GET ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED ONE DOLLARS PER CASE
WHILE THE REMAINING STAKE IT'S
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
DOLLARS PER CASE.
THIS FUNDING METHODOLOGY IN THE
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
BRING IN I'M PUTS -- BASELINE
FUNDING -- EXPECTATION OUT THERE
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE AND THIS
IS MINIMUM THRESHOLD THAT WE
FEEL IS IMPORTANT FOR CARRYING
OUT THE BUSINESS OF CHILD
SUPPORT.
SO THAT WE'VE GOT THAT EQUITY
ACROSS THE AND START IT
INTERSTATE IS NOT HERE SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE DEPARTMENT TWO
THOUSAND ONE THERE HAS BEEN
SEVERAL ATTEMPTS AT FUNDING
METHODOLOGIES NONE OF COME
THROUGH.
THEM SO FAR AND SO THERE'S BEEN
NO ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
ALLOCATIONS OF THE LOCAL
TRANSFERRED AGENCIES EXCEPT FOR
PEACE MINOR -- INFLUXES OF MONEY
SINCE THAT TIME SO WE'RE HOPING
TO RECTIFY THAT HIM AND GET
SOMETHING MOVING FORWARD -- IF
YOU'D LIKE WE CAN GO THROUGH
THAT BUDGET PROPOSAL A BIT MORE
DETAIL.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE.
INTRODUCED MANSION OUR CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER.
THANK HIGH SOME.
HER NAME'S MANSION AND CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT -- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY COME TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES REQUEST ONE POINT ONE
BILLION THREE HUNDRED THREE NINE
NINE GENERAL FUND FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWO IN.
NINETEEN I'M THIS IS AN INCREASE
OF SIXTY ONE MILLION COMPARED TO
THE UNITED BUDGET.
THE SIX SEVEN MAJORITY OR FIFTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS I'M OF THIS
INCREASES FOR THE APARTMENTS
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY
BUDGET ALLOCATION PROPOSAL -- IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET CYCLE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH THE
CHILD SUPPORTDIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. TO SOLVE THE LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY FUNDING
ISSUE THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
FAMILY CODE SEVENTEEN SEVEN OH
FIVE WHICH QUALIFIES THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN DECSS AND
CSTA TOWARDS THIS EFFORT.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE DID
WE SET FORWARD -- TO WORK
TOGETHER AND THE RESULT OF THIS
EFFORT WAS PUT FORWARD IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE PROPOSAL REQUESTS FIFTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS NINETEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
OR SIXTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
THIS REQUEST IS BASED ON AN
IMPROVED LCS ALLOCATION OF
METHODOLGY DOES BUILD ON THE
MOMENTUM VOTE WAS PUT FORWARD IN
THE SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE PROPOSAL THE
PROPOSED METHODOLOGY CONTINUES
TO USE THE IDEOLOGY.
OF A CASE TO F. T. RATIO BUT
GOES FURTHER TO BUILD OUT OTHER
COMPONENTS NECESSARY TO FUND LCS
THE OPERATIONS.
AS WELL AS ESTABLISHING A CASE
F. T. E. RATIO BASED ON WORKLOAD
PATRICK'S.
THIS REPRESENTS A BALANCED
APPROACH OF IMPROVING CUSTOMER
OUTCOMES THE FAMILIES ADDRESSING
LCS A CURRENT AND FUTURE COST
PRESSURES AND EFFICIENCIES OF
SHARED SERVICES.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE METHODOLOGY
ENCOMPASSES THREE MAJOR
COMPONENTS BASE LEVEL OF
STAFFING FOR CASE WORK
OPERATIONS CALL CENTER
OPERATIONS AND PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVES.
IT IS BUILT UPON I CORPS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WAS THE
HOLD HARMLESS DEAL CSA'S THAT
WORK BETTER CURRENTLY FUNDED
MORE THAN WHAT THE METHODOLOGY
CALCULATED.
THIS WOULD AVOID STAFFING
LAYOFFS THAT WILL NEGATIVELY
IMPACT COUNTY PERFORMANCE.
BUT IT WOULD ALSO SET AN
EXPECTATION THAT THESE -- CSA'S
WILL MANAGE THEIR EXISTING
RESOURCES THROUGH ATTRITION TELL
COST PRESSURES BRING THEM UP TO
THE CALCULATED ALLOCATION.
THE CURRENT STATE WHAT
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY WELL THE
REALLY IS LACKEY METHODOLOGY
TODAY.
AND THERE IS NO MECHANISM TO
FIND SALARIES AND WAGES
INCREASES BENEFIT INCREASES THAT
HAVE CONTINUED TO GROSS -- OVER
THE LAST DECADE -- SAYS IS HAVE
OPERATED THROUGH STAFFING
REDUCTIONS AND AT RISK OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE DEGRADATION
PRODUCTIONS CONTINUE -- THE
AGENDA DOES A GREAT JOB OF
EXPLAINING THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA SO KEEP MY COMMENTS
SHORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS MARIE -- LET I'M THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME I LOVE
HEARING THE WORD SAN BERNADINO
NOW.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR IS IN A
STEAM COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF NOT ONLY SAN
BERNADINO BUT ALSO THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
WHICH I AM THE TREASURE.
AS WELL AS THE FORTY NINE
MEMBERS OF THAT ASSOCIATION.
THE FUNDING PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
ALIGNS VERY WELL WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LARGER POLICY
GOALS OF LIFTING CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY.
THIS INCREASE IN LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT FUNDING WILL RESULT IN
BETTER LIVES FOR ABOUT ONE POINT
THREE MILLION CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT OF
NINETEEN POINT ONE MILLION IS
MATCH TWO TO ONE WITH AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY SIX POINT NINE
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE UNDERLYING BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY IS INTENDED TO BE
ROLLED OUT OVER FOUR YEARS.
REGIONAL CALL CENTER FUNDING IS
INCLUDED FOR MERE ONE AND
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE FUNDS ARE
ADDED TO THE METHODOLOGY IN YOUR
FOR THE CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HAS WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES TO DETERMINE THE
FUNDING NEEDS OF LOCAL.
VOTE OF THE LOCAL AGENCIES AND
TO IDENTIFY THOSE COUNTIES WITH
THE LOWEST LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR
THEIR CASE SIZE.
AS IT HAPPENS THOSE TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES ARE ALSO AMONG THE
POOREST OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES.
THE IMPACT OF LIMITED FUNDING ON
POVERTY AVOIDANCE IS CLEAR LESS
SPENDING RESULTS IN GREATER
INSTANCE OF POVERTY.
AND THAT IS EQUALLY TRUE IN
CHILD SUPPORT.
CHILD SUPPORT IS MANDATED BY
FEDERAL REGULATION THE OFFICE OF
CHILD SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT UNDER
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION OF
CHILDREN'S AND FAT CHILDREN
FAMILIES.
HAS RECENTLY PROMULGATED WHAT IS
KNOWN AS THE FINAL RULE.
MOST OF THESE CHANGES TO THE
VARIOUS STATES PROGRAMS IN THE
FINAL RULE REQUIRE A SHIFT FROM
SYSTEM GENERATED TASKS TO A MORE
HUMAN CENTRIC TASK.
THAT HUMAN CENTRIC MODE WILL
LIKELY BE MORE COSTLY THAN THE
SYSTEM GENERATED PROGRAM WITH
MIGRATED TO UNDER PRESSURE OF
LIMITED FUNDING.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN SOCIAL
POLICY AND HAS ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED MOST OF THE FINAL
RULE RECOMMENDATIONS HOWEVER
MANY LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES LACKS SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT
REMAINING FEDERAL CHANGES.
AND REACH ADDITIONAL FAMILIES
THAT COULD NOT PARTICIPATE IN
THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM.
THE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES
IDENTIFIED IN THE PROPOSED
FUNDING HAVE BEEN TREADING WATER
HOWEVER EACH YEAR WITH THE
LIMITED FUNDS AVAILABLE THEY
OFFER INNOVATIVE SERVICES
INCLUDING.
REFERRALS FOR EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES POP UP AND MOBILE
OFFICES OUT REACH TO
INCARCERATED PARENTS
ESTABLISHING ORDERS FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE AND DEVELOPING
ACHIEVABLE PAYMENT PLANS.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT VARIATIONS
IN FUNDING BETWEEN COUNTIES
WHICH AFFECTS PERFORMANCE AND
SERVICE TO FAMILIES.
THE PROPOSED SPENDING IS A
PRELIMINARY STEP TOWARD A
REASONABLE FUNDING METHODOLOGY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE SUPPORT ALL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST REITERATE A LOT
OF WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID
WHICH IS THAT.
THEY'LL SAY SAY FUNNY PROPOSALS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD BUDGET PACKAGE WHICH
IS ONE OF HIS PRIORITIES.
SPECIFICALLY THIS INVESTMENT IS
INTENDED TO EASE THE FINANCIAL
PRESSURES ON PARENTS THINKING
ESCAPE THE CYCLE OF POVERTY AND
FOCUS ON THE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT.
OF THEIR CHILDREN THE
ADMINISTRATION VIEWS THIS
INVESTMENT AS A BASELINE
ADJUSTMENT TO CREATE A MORE
EQUITABLE FUNDING DISTRIBUTION
ACROSS ALL COUNTIES AND REDUCE
GEOGRAPHIC AND DEMOGRAPHIC
DISPARITIES IN FUNDING.
AFTER FULL IMPLEMENTATION THE
INCREASE COLLECTIONS RESULTING
FROM THIS INVESTMENT WILL
DIRECTLY BENEFIT FAMILIES AND
REDUCE CHILD POVERTY
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THAT TEND TO BE
CONCENTRATED IN THE LCS SAYS
THEY'RE CURRENTLY RELATIVELY
UNDERFUNDED.
AND HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
JACQUELINE ROSY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
A FEW WEEKS AGO OUR OFFICE
RELEASED A REPORT IN WHICH WE
DID AN ANALYSIS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IN THE REPORT WEEK KNOWLEDGE
THAT YES THERE AND IS CONCERNED
ABOUT FINDING AND HOW THAT IS --
DECIDED IN TERMS OF FUNDING
LEVELS FOR EACH LTSA -- WITH
REGARD TO THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THE PROPOSED NEW
METHODOLOGY WE DID RAISE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS -- ONE BEING
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S
PREMATURE FOR TWO REASONS -- AS
WAS NOTED -- IN THE AGENDA ON
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE DID
PASS SOME REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT TO
LOOK FOR OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES BOTH OF THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVELS.
THAT WOULD THEN AND FORMER FINE
MINTS TO THE BUDGET METHODOLOGY
THAT SPECIFIC COMPONENT OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES IS DUE
BY.
JULY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN I'M
GIVEN THAT THAT IS PENDING --
DEPENDING ON THE FINDINGS OF
THAT REPORT -- THOSE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES COULD HAVE SOME
IMPLICATIONS ON BOTH THE AMOUNT
OF TIME IT TAKES TO DO --
EVERYDAY TASK OR RUN --
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM -- BUT
THEN ALSO -- DOES A COULD --
INFORM DIFFERENCES AND FUNDING
LEVELS AND ALSO HOW FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED ACROSS ALL CSA'S
ANOTHER REASON WHY WE FLAGS THAT
THIS PROPOSAL THAT THE
METHODOLOGY IN AND OF ITSELF MAY
BE PREMATURE.
AS WAS MENTIONED THE DEPARTMENT
IS UNDERGOING -- A SERIES OF
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF
THE FEDERAL FINAL RULE -- AS WAS
NOTED SOME OF THESE COMPONENTS --
COULD AFFECT -- EVERYDAY
OPERATIONS OF THE PROGRAM EITHER
REQUIRING MORE -- HUMAN CENTERED
TOUCHES THAT COULD THEN REQUIRE
HIGHER LEVELS OF A EFFORT -- BUT
THEN ALSO MORE COST -- SO UNTIL
WE HAVE A PLANT ON HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS THAT WE FIND
THAT [inaudible]
I'M.
ADOPTING OF BUDGET METHODOLOGY
MAY BE PREMATURE AT THAT TIME
SETTING ON THOSE DIVIDE TWO
CONCERNS ASIDE WE DID REVIEW THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND ALSO RAISED A
NUMBER OF TECHNICAL CONCERNS.
I'M SOME OF THAT INCLUDES -- IN
IT AND THERE ARE SET AS IN THE
CALCULATION OF BASELINE STAFFING
LEVELS A LEVEL OF EFFORT STUDY
WAS CONDUCTED IN WHICH THEY
SURVEYED FIFTEEN COUNTIES.
LOOK DAD A MANDATED TASK TASK
THAT ARE NEEDED JUST TO WORK AS
AN EVERYDAY CHILD SUPPORT CASE --
AND THEN TRY TO TIME EACH TASK
OUT TO THEN DETERMINE THE
NECESSARY -- EMPLOYEES AND
THAT'S REQUIRED TO WORK A CASE.
THAT LEVEL OF EFFORT STUDY ONLY
PARTIALLY INFORMED TO THE
OVERALL BASE LEVEL OF STAFF.
THAT THEY REACHED BUT EVEN
WITHIN THAT LEVEL OF EFFORT
STUDY IT DID DEMONSTRATE WIDE
VARIATION AND HOW THE PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED ACROSS ALSEA ESSAYS --
AGAIN THAT IN IT OF ITSELF --
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE IS SOME
LEVEL OF WIDE VARIATION IN HOW
THE PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED AND
THAT COULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
THEN EVALUATE OUR THEIR
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES OR BEST
PRACTICES THAT COULD BE LEARNED
FROM CERTAIN LC ESSAYS.
AND THEN IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE
SYSTEM ON THE PROPOSAL AS
OPPOSED OF TAKING THAT APPROACH
OF FUNDING TO THE BEST PRACTICE
LEVEL JUST -- PICKED AN AVERAGE --
SO IT HAS THOSE BIG TEN
VARIATIONS AND THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF AND LASTLY AS AS WAS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA.
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT -- KEY
COMPONENTS THAT ARE MISSING THAT --
WOULD FACILITATE SOME FORM OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT BOTH IN
TERMS OF KNOWING HOW THE DOLLARS
ARE SPENT ULTIMATELY BUTALSO A
LACK OF METRICS OR A LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'RE
GONNA GAP -- FROM THE DOLLARS
I'M IN THE REPORT.
AS I SAID IN THE BEGINNING OF MY
COMMENTS WE DID ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FUNDING IS A CONCERN -- SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DO IN THE MEANTIME IS THAT
WHILE IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ACCURATELY ASSESS WHICH ALL
CSA'S.
MAY BE UNABLE TO PERFORM CORE
FUNCTIONS YOU TO BUDGETARY
CONSTRAINTS THE LEGISLATURE
COULD PROVIDE STOP GAP FUNDING.
AND ONE OF ONE OPTION IN THAT
STOP GAP FUNDING COULD BE TO
PROVIDE AN INFLATION ADJUSTMENT
TO ALL LCS SEASON -- TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT THAT'S JUST AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT FUNDING IS
AN ISSUE SOME OF THESE CAN
COMPONENTS LIKE THE LEGISLATIVE
REPORT THAT'S DUE JULY FIRST AND
THE APPROACH TO THE FEDERAL
FINAL ROLE ARE PENDING.
AND ONCE WE GET FURTHER CLARITY
ON THAT I THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO
THEN READJUST AND TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF ACTUAL FUNDING
NEEDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
WE'RE ALL DONE.
ALL RIGHT -- WHY DON'T WE OPEN
THIS UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT THEM
[inaudible]
SOMEBODY FIRST.
SORRY HAVE LOST A BIT OF MY
VOICE.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE DAILY --
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF A COLUSA
SATTAR AND YOLO COUNTIES CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES.
ALTHOUGH THESE THREE COUNTIES
ARE NOT PART OF THE TWENTY ONE
SLATED FOR THE ENHANCED FUNDING
RECOGNIZED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET METHODOLOGY.
WE ALL THREE COUNTIES ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THIS FUNDING METHODOLOGY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
I IS PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION CO
FACILITATED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE WORK GROUP THAT DEVELOPED
THIS FUNDING METHODOLOGY.
IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE THAT
WE IMPLEMENT THIS FUNDING
METHODOLOGY SO THAT IN THREE
YEARS WE CAN REPORT ON ITS
EFFICACY AND HOW IT'S ADDRESSED
TO A POT CHILD POVERTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND IS FOR THESE
REASONS AUTHOR KENNY SUPPORT THE
SPENDING THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON -- JODY HAYES
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
STANISLAUS COUNTY.
HERE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- CHILD SUPPORT DOES
TREMENDOUS WORK IN A COMMUNITY
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD MUCH OF
THAT IN THE STAFF COMMENTS -- IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY WE GENERATE
ABOUT FOUR DOLLARS BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR
SPENT.
WE SERVE TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
CHILDREN BRING IN FORTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS PROPOSAL PUTS US AT LEAST
ON A PATH TO SUSTAINABILITY IN
THE FUTURE WHERE AS WE'VE BEEN
FLAT FUNDED FOR ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS NOW IN THIS PROGRAM. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IS HIGHLIGHTED IS
THAT WE'RE LEVERAGING TWO
DOLLARS OF FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
EVERYONE DOLLAR OF STATE FUNDS
IN THIS PROPOSAL -- BUT THERE
ARE NUMEROUS BENEFITS -- MANY OF
WHICH WERE ALREADY MENTIONED
HERE.
THIS PUTS FOOD DIRECTLY ON THE
TABLE IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY AND
IT HURT IN IT HELPS SOME OF
THOSE I AM MOST NEEDY --
DEFINITELY IMPROVE SELF
SUFFICIENCY IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHICH WERE FOCUSED ON STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND THE ONE ITEM THAT WE
HAVE NOTICED -- THE MOST OUR
COMMUNITY ARE THOSE STORIES OF
REUNIFICATION OF PARENTS IT'S
NOT WHAT USUALLY GETS TALKED
ABOUT IN THE CHILD SUPPORT.
A CONVERSATION -- BUT SOME OF
THE BEST EXAMPLES OF POSITIVE
WORK AND IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAPPEN OUR CHILD
SUPPORT DEPARTMENT WHEN WE DO
HAVE RENO YEAH REUNIFIED
FAMILIES.
AN ABSENTEE PARENTS THAT AND TO
THE LIVES OF THEIR CHILDREN
AGAIN THAT PAYS NOT JUST THE TWO
TO ONE AND THE FOUR TO ONE RATIO
THAT PACE.
MUCH MUCH MORE DOWNSTREAM IN
THIS PROCESS SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE WARDELL
TRY HOME THE DIRECTOR OF THE
MERCED MARIPOSA REGIONAL
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES -- MY COUNTIES SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
AND APPRECIATE HIS RECOGNITION
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK
THAT OUR PROGRAM DOES.
THE CHOPPER PROGRAM'S TERMS OF
THE MARKET COMMUNITIES MOST
FRAGILE FAMILIES IN MERCED
COUNTY 44% OF FAMILIES WITH
SINGLE MOTHERS ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY AND 27% OF CHILDREN ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY.
OUR LOCAL PROGRAM CREATES
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR
THE FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
OF THE TWENTY SIX MILLION
COLLECTED LAST YEAR OVER TWENTY
THREE MILLION WENT DIRECTLY TO
FAMILIES -- EITHER.
FORMALLY OFF AID OR HAVE NEVER
RECEIVED AID.
AS A RURAL COMMUNITY STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE LAST
RECESSION THE CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM IS A NECESSARY AND
VALUABLE TOOL IN OUR EFFORTS TO
REDUCE POVERTY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR
STEPHEN GOLIGHTLY I'M DIRECTOR
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
I SPENT OVER FOUR DECADES OF MY
LIFE WORKING AND PROGRAMS
FOCUSING ON LOW INCOME CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES.
AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM MY
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE CHILD
SUPPORT. ONE OF THE MOST COMPLEX
AND ONE OF THE MOST REWARDING
PROGRAMS I'VE EVER WORKED IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
BOB WE KNOW THAT TO A CHILD
SUPPORT IS ONE OF THE TOP THREE
ANTI POVERTY PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION.
LAST YEAR IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE COLLECTED ALMOST ONE HALF OF
THE BILLION DOLLARS. 88% OF OUR
COLLECTIONS WENT DIRECTLY TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
WE HAVE.
MILLION CASES LOCATED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES AND
THIRTY NINE FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
THROUGHOUT WERE A BIG OPERATION
AND I GET TO SEE EVERY DAY THE
IMPACT IN OUR LOBBY SO FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN THE COMMAND.
WHEN I SIT AND TALK TO THEM?
NOT EVERYONE IS HAPPY OBVIOUSLY
BUT IN THE INSTANCES WHERE WE'RE
ABLE TO SEE DIRECTLY HOW THE
FUNDS THAT WE COLLECT.
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE LOW INCOME AND POOR WE'RE
WORKING CONTINUOUSLY. TO REDO
OUR BUSINESS MODEL TO BE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE OUR MOTTO WE STAY
CONTINUOUSLY AS WE SERVE ONE
FAMILY AT A TIME -- WE ARE NOT
SURPRISINGLY OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS UNANIMOUSLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
AND QUITE FRANKLY WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO
THAT WE CAN REDUCE THE CASELOAD
SIZE SO THAT WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB OF SERVING THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN OUR BACKYARD.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE MONEY MACHON FERAL IN
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE BUTTE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
MY DEPARTMENT IS HOME TO ONE OF
THE STATE'S EXIST EXISTING CALL
CENTERS IN ADDITION TO OUR OWN
CALLS WE WE SERVE NINE OTHER
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES.
WHICH REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND CALLS PER
MONTH.
MORE THAN MONEY RUNNING A CALL
CENTER REQUIRES SKILL AND
TRAINING AND WE'RE PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS SERVICE TO
OTHER CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES --
WE DO IT BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
TRYING TO HELP THE PROGRAM
BECOME BETTER.
THE PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD ALLOW
FOR MORE THIS TYPE OF INNOVATION
AND STATEWIDE EFFICIENCY FOR
THESE REASONS EVEN THOUGH BIãU
WOULD NOT BE A RECIPIENT OF THE
OF THE FUNDING -- WE SUPPORT THE
THE FUNNY PROPOSAL FOR THE
REASONS I STATED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR REYES
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LAURIE CRUZ I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES.
TRANSPORT PROGRAM HAS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN PERCEIVED AS
A COLLECTION REMEDY THAT FOCUSES
ON REIMBURSING THE GOVERNMENT
FOR ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS.
THAT PERCEPTION IS NO LONGER
REALITY IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
THE CHILD SUPPORT TEAM COLLECTED
SIXTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR 171886%
OF THOSE DOLLARS WENT DIRECTLY
TO FAMILIES AND CHILDREN IN MY
COUNTY TO PARENTS TO PAY FOR
CHILDREN'S FOOD CLOTHING AND
THEIR OTHER NEEDS. FOR FRAGILE
FAMILIES THE CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM IS AN ANTI POVERTY
MEASURE.
IN CALIFORNIA 18% OF CHILDREN UP
TO AGE.
SEVENTEEN LIVE IN HOMES WHERE
THE ANNUAL HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS
OF NO MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CHILD SUPPORT IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT AND SUPPORTING
CHILDREN.
WHOSE PARENTS OR LESSEN THE
FEDERAL POVERTY THRESHOLD.
IN FACT CHILD SUPPORT MAKES UP
40% OF THE HOUSEHOLD INCOME FOR
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED FAMILIES.
THE GOVERNOR'S FUNDING REQUEST
FOR LOCAL TRIALS FOR AGENCIES
ONE ABLE UNDERFUNDED TOLD FOR
AGENCIES TO HIRE ADDITIONAL CASE
WORKERS.
THAT ARE VITALLY NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE THE CASE WORK TO TURN A
PERRANCE REQUEST FOR HELP.
INTO A CHILD SUPPORT JUDGMENT IN
TURN SURE THAT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES RECEIVED CONSISTENT.
AND RELIABLE CHILD FOR EACH
MONTH.
WENT BY THE WAY I LIVE IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY NOT LONG AGO.
YEAH A WELCOME BACK WHEN YOU
WANT TO COME BACK.
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- ONE EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE GOVERNOR IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING
THIS IN THE CHILDHOOD POVERTY
PACKAGE.
I'M AS WELL AS THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE IS
FOR MOVING THIS CONVERSATION
ALONG LAST YEAR ON THE
METHODOLOGY IN GETTING US TO THE
POINT WE ARE TODAY WITH THIS
PROPOSED METHODOLOGY.
I REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT
UNDERTAKING BETWEEN THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT -- AND
THE TIME IS RIGHT TO MAKE THIS
INVESTMENT -- AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS PROPOSED METHODOLOGY --
THEY WILL HELP.
I'M INCREASE FUNDING IN THESE
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES TO REDUCE
POVERTY INCREASE SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M MELINDA SELF DIRECTOR FOR
THE COUNTRY COSTA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES ONE OF THE TWENTY
IDENTITY TWENTY ONE IDENTIFIED
UNDERFUNDED COUNTIES.
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY RECEIPT OF CHILD
SUPPORT FOR MOST OF OUR
CUSTODIAL PARTIES.
IS THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN AFFORD
TO PROVIDE SHELTER FOOD AND
CLOTHING FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND OUR STAFFING
LEVEL HAS GONE FROM A HIGH OF
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES TO ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
TODAY.
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN UR
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR THE NEXT
STATE FISCAL YEAR AT THE CURRENT
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE LEVEL 91% OF MY FUNDING
FOR OUR COUNTY.
WILL BE USED FOR SALARY AND
BENEFITS WHICH MEANS THAT I HAVE
TO CUT POSITIONS.
WE'VE BEEN KNOWN IN CONTRA COSTA
AS AN INNOVATOR OF TECHNOLOGY TO
AUTOMATE AS MANY OF THE WORK
FUNCTIONS THAT WE CAN AND WE ARE
OUT OF THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
WE'VE AUTOMATED EVERYTHING THAT
WE POSSIBLY CAN.
IN ORDER TO MAKE UP FOR THE
DWINDLING STAFFING WE
DESPERATELY NEED AN INCREASE IN
OUR FUNDING AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BENJAMIN PALMER
BEHALF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
WE ARE INSUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES AND REALLY APPRECIATE --
THE GOVERNOR'S ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE IN TERMS OF THE LARGER
DISCUSSION AROUND CHILDHOOD
POVERTY JUST A REMINDER FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT CHILDREN WHO GROW
UP IN DEEP POVERTY -- HAVE
IMPACTS TO THEIR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT TO THEIR HEALTH
OUTCOMES INTO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES SO THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT AND FROM THE LONG
TERM HEALTH OF CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI A KERR GILBERT FRESNO COUNTY
JAILS FOR SERVICES DIRECTOR I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR COUNTY
ASKING THAT YOU DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND THINKING ABOUT THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
WE WORK TOGETHER TO CONSTANTLY
LOOK AT IMPROVING OUR PROGRAM AS
LOCAL ENTITIES WE ALL LOOK AT
WHAT WE CAN DO INDIVIDUALLY BUT
WE DO COME TOGETHER COLLECTIVELY
AND WE'VE SPENT THE LAST YEAR.
REALLY DIGGING DEEP TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN DO -- IN
ADDITION TO GETTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT MANY OF US THE
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES WE ARE AT A
BREAKING POINT AND IN ORDER TO
SERVE THE CUSTOMERS THAT WE DO
HAVE.
AND REACH OUT TO PEOPLE WHO DO
NOT EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP THEM WE ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND WE ASK THAT YOU DO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF
THE CURRENT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL I REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WHEN THAT CHILD
SUPPORT DEPARTMENTS FOR SPLIT
OUT OF THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IS ABOUT. TWO DECADES AGO.
THE WHATEVER YOU GOT AT THAT
TIME IS WHAT YOU GOT AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN GETTING WITH A
LITTLE TINY BIT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NAUTICAL AND
NOTHING SO WHATEVER DOLLAR
AMOUNT YOU GOT IS WHAT YOU GET.
AND AS PART OF THAT AGREEMENT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE A FORMULA
ACTUALLY STYLISH BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T ONE AT THE TIME. THREE
EFFORTS ROUNDER TAKEN BY THE
STATE TO DEVELOP A FORMULA AND
THEY NEVER REACHED WHEN.
THEY'RE HERE BEFORE YOU THE
WHOLE ASSOCIATION EVEN THE
COUNTIES ARE GETTING ANYBODY TO
TELL YOU THAT THEY REACHED
AGREEMENT.
SO WE HEAR THE LA -- INSANE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A REPORT COMING ON
JULY ONE WILL JULY WHEN IS
UNFORTUNATELY JUST WHEN THE NEW
BUDGET START SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT -- THE FUNDING CAN MOVE OUT
AND THEY CAN MAKE REFINEMENTS TO
THE FORMULAS THEY CAN MOVE
FORWARD BUT THEY FINALLY REACHED
A FORMULA SO PLEASE DON'T LET
THAT WERE CUT AWAY THREE URGE
YOUR APPROVAL AND THANK YOU TO
THE GOVERNOR IS A PERMANENT
FINANCE FOR INCLUDING THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEVON ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
TIFFANY WHITE WITH THAT CA YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
IN PARTICULAR THOSE MEMBERS THAT --
COLLECT THE CHILD SUPPORT WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AND ASK
THAT YOU DO THE THING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PHYLLIS STANCE I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
ALAMEDA COUNTIES -- STRONGLY
APPRECIATES AND IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECOGNITION.
OF THE IMPORTANCE THE CHILD
SUPPORT PAID PLAYS IN HELPING
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY.
AS THE DIRECTOR OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE ROLE THAT WE PLAY
AND THAT CHILD SUPPORT IS A
SAFETY NET FOR FAMILIES.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WE HAVE OVER
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND CASES WE
COLLECTED OVER EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR AND 84% FAN OF
THAT.
COLLECTION WENT TO THE FAMILIES.
WE HAVE A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE METHODOLOGY AND THE
NUMBERS.
BUT THE REAL DISCUSSION IS THAT
THIS FUNDING HAS AN IMPACT A
HUMAN IMPACT TO THE FAMILIES
THAT WE SERVE.
IN ALAMEDA AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND
ALAMEDA NOT OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
WE REALLY STRONGLY -- WHICH WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU -- TO
EXCEPT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU.
HELLO I FIGURE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT -- TERREUS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CRAIG WILSON I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT ASSOCIATION -- WE OF
COURSE AS A BIG PART OF THE
PROPOSAL IS BIG BEFORE YOU GO
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE LEVEL OF
EFFORT STUDY ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
THE NEW FUNDING. TO MISS NANCY
IS POINT THAT THIS IS -- HUMAN
EFFORT THE MONEY THAT'S
COLLECTED FROM ONE PARENT AND
PROVIDED TO ANOTHER -- VIA THE
WORK THAT THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS DO THROUGHOUT THE
STATE'S PUTS CHEERIOS ON THE
TABLE SPEAKERS ON THE FIGHT ON
THE FEET OF THE CHILDREN.
AND A BACKPACK FOR THEM TO GO TO
SCHOOL WITH AND ABSOLUTELY DOES
IMPACT CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE MEASURE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CHILDREN IN WEEKS AND MONTHS SIX
MONTHS IS A LONG TIME IN A
CHILD'S LIFE A YEAR IS A LONG
TIME IN A CHILD'S LIFE. EIGHTEEN
YEARS IT'S AN ENTIRE CHILD'S
LIFE AND WE'VE GONE EIGHTEEN
YEARS WITHOUT A FUNDING INCREASE
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO MISS ANYMORE
MONTHS OR WEEKS IN THE
CHILDREN'S LIVES WE WOULD URGE
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JESSICA BARTH LOW
IN THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
HAVE A CHILD SUPPORT SYSTEM WE
HAVE AGENCIES IN AT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT ARE DOING THE JOB
OF COLLECTING FROM THE NON
CUSTODIAL PARENT -- THE THE
MONEY OWED TO THE CUSTODIAL
PARENT OR FOR THE CASE OF
WELFARE RECIPIENTS TO THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REMEMBER
THAT FOR THOSE RECIPIENTS ONLY
FIFTY DOLLARS.
OF THE BENEFIT IS PASSED THROUGH
A TO THEM FOR MOST CASES -- WE
THINK THAT THESE AGENCIES SHOULD
BE.
WELL STAFFED THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THESE ON THE BILL
FAMILIES IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WE'RE WE'RE HOPING TO BE PART OF
THE SHIFT TO MORE FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT -- MORE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR FOR BOTH PARENTS TO
HELP THEM DO THE GOOD JOB OF
GOOD PARENTING AND SUB AND
BECAUSE SUPPORTER OF THIS CHILD --
AND SO OUR SUPPORT OF OF OF THE
EFFORT TO TO CORRECTLY AND
ADEQUATELY FUND ON THIS WORK YOU
WILL SEE OUR PROPOSAL THAT WE
HOPE CAN ACCOMPANY THIS FUNDING --
AND THE NEXT AND THE NEXT ITEM --
BUT WOULD JUST LIKE TO GO ON
RECORD TO SAY THAT WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS WE THINK THAT
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVANTS SHOULD
PROVIDE THIS WORK AND WE THINK
THAT THEY SHOULD BE FUNDED TO DO
IT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES
MOST FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'M LOOKING ON PAGE.
TWENTY THE COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PERFORMANCE -- IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PAGE.
THE RATIO TOTAL COLLECTIONS TO
TOTAL PROGRAM COST.
CAN SOMEBODY SHARE WITH ME IS
THAT TWO DOLLARS FIFTY CENTS PER
DOLLAR RECOVERED.
IT'S STILL AS A FIFTY CENTS
DISTRIBUTED OUT AM PER DOLLAR A
CUSTOMER IN THE PROGRAM.
OKAY SO WHAT WAS THE
EFFICIENCIES PER. FOR FOR MONEY
SPENT WHAT HAS BEEN COLLECTED.
FROM WHEN WE HAVE THAT.
OUR BUDGET IS ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN AND WE
DISTRIBUTE OUT THE TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS SO THAT'S
THE TWO DOLLARS OF IT AS A
RECOVERY.
THE RECOVERY P. SPECIFICALLY IS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS GOES
TOWARDS RECOVERY 50% THAT GOES
TO THE FEDS TO RECOVER ON THEIR
BEHALF.
RETAIN FORTY SEVEN POINT 5% OF
THAT AND THE TWO POINT 5% IS
RECOUPED IN RETURN TO THE
COUNTIES.
OKAY.
SO THERE'S A REPORT THAT SAYS
IT'S DUE IN.
JULY FIRST I BELIEVE THAT'S
CORRECT -- COULD WE HAVE
ACCELERATED THAT DATE BEFORE
BUDGET.
SO THAT WE COULD BE MORE
INFORMED.
A GOING FOR I KNOW WE ALWAYS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TRAILER BILL
LATER.
BUT WHY WOULDN'T WE HAVE IT
BEFORE MAY REVISE SO WE WERE
GIVEN.
TO REQUIREMENTS LAST YEAR TO THE
BUDGET CYCLE ONE WAS TO CREATE
THIS METHODOLOGY IN THE SECOND
WAS TO WORK ON EFFICIENCIES --
SO WE SPENT A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE FIRST PART OF
LAST YEAR -- GELLING INTO
JANUARY THIS YEAR TRYING TO GET
THAT BUDGET METHODOLOGY IN PLACE
IN TIME FOR THE GOVERNOR PUT OUT
HIS BUDGET AS SOON AS THAT WAS
AND WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
DEFICIENCIES REPORT.
THAT'S UNDER DEVELOPMENT RIGHT
NOW WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD TO
TRY AND GET THAT OUT BY JULY
FIRST.
SOARING APRIL DO YOU HAVE A
DRAFT.
WE HAVE A AT THE START OF
CHAPTER THINK ALL OF THE PIECES
ARE PUT TOGETHER WORKING ON THE
FINALIZATION THERE.
THERE ARE EFFICIENCIES IN IT
THERE'S THERE'S DEFINITELY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM TO IMPROVE THEIR
NOT EFFICIENCIES IN THAT REPORT
THAT ARE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN%
SAVINGS TOWARDS MOVING AS A LOT
OF THE EFFICIENCIES THAT WE ARE
BEING.
WE ARE HIGHLIGHTING AND REALLY
GO TOWARDS MORE EFFICIENTLY
DELIVERING THE SERVICES THAN THE
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM.
THERE ARE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THE CALL CENTER RE AT
REGIONALIZATION THE CALL CENTERS
WAS A A BIG COST SAVINGS FOR THE
STATE I THINK THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE TRAINING
ENVIRONMENT AND A FEW THINGS
LIKE THAT TO REGIONALES
TRAININGS AND REALIZE SOME OF
THE SPECIALTY TYPE SERVICES.
THE CORE OF WHAT WE DO THOUGH AT
THE LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
IS ABOUT AN INDIVIDUAL SITTING
IN FRONT OF FAMILY -- AND
WORKING ON THEIR FINANCIAL
ISSUES TO GET IT OUT THERE SO
THERE ISN'T A WHOLE LOT MORE
WE'VE ALREADY SPENT TWO DECADES
REALLY TRYING TO REFINE
OURSELVES AND MAINTAIN SERVICES
WITH THAT WITH THE DWINDLING
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
THAT BEING SAID WHAT IS YOUR
RETENTION RATE ON YOUR CASE
MANAGERS -- GOING FORWARD I MEAN --
HEARING OTHER AGENCIES -- SAYING
HER EMPLOYEES ARE UNDERPAID.
AND FIND BETTER PAYING JOBS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHAT'S YOUR
RETENTION READER YOUR AVERAGE --
STAY FOR YOUR EMPLOYER YOUR OF
TV'S AND I DON'T HAVE THAT FOR
EVERY COUNTY BUT IN MY TOUR DAY
GETTING TO THE STATE SPOT I'VE
BEEN IN FOUR DIFFERENT COUNTIES
TO LARRY LOS ANGELES SAM AND
DEAN ON RIVER SIGN IN AND ALL OF
THOSE INSTANCES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF STAFF STAY
IN THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM FOR
VERY LONG TIME AS AN AFFECT THEM
I DARE SAY THAT THE THE
DIRECTORS ARE ACTUALLY FACING A
LARGE CONTINGENT STAFF THAT ARE
READY TO RETIRE AND WALK OUT THE
DOOR.
AND SO THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
GEARING UP TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO REPLACE
THOSE BUT FROM A FUNDING
PERSPECTIVE OF THE
CLASSIFICATION THE COR CASE
WORKER CLASSIFICATION.
WE DON'T SEE A LOT OF TURNOVER
IN THAT IN THAT TOWN IN THAT
ROLE THANK THEM FOR ME I
CERTAINLY WILL [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD.
I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AND OF
COURSE IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM LA -- OF
BUT I DO WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ENVISIONS A HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO ASSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
MY COUNTY STANDS TO GAIN
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AFTER LOS ANGELES -- SUMMER TO
DO NO COUNTY WOULD RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN AT THE VERY
BOTTOM FOR SO LONG.
SO.
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING WE
WANT THAT?
THE METHODOLOGY HOUSE TO BE IN
PLACE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY HOW THEY WERE.
WE WE NEED SOMETHING THERE'S
MORE THOUGHT FOR MARK MORE
COLLABORATIVE.
SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO USE THE GOVERNOR'S
MONEY.
AND THEN WE NEED TO CODIFY IT.
OF SO WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE.
ON THE APPROACH BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE -- TO ADD TO IT
THAT WE'VE OUTLINED ON PAGE.
TWENTY SEVEN IN THE AGENDA.
SO SIMILAR TO THAT THE THE WHOLE
OVER FUNDING THAT WAS PUT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET LAST YEAR THE
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS WAS REALLY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE FEDERALLY
MATCHED -- YOU CAN KIND OF SEE
THE S. MAY NEW F. TO EASE THAT
WERE AND THE NEED TO BE BROAD
ENOUGH THAT MONEY THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION THAT THIS MONEY
PREDOMINATELY GOES TOWARDS.
AND THE INCREASE IN STAFF AND
THESE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES THE
GOAL IS TO GET THEM TO THAT --
FTE CASELOAD RATIO THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING IN THE IN THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
SPECIFICALLY HARD AND FAST TO TO
NECESSARILY HOLD THE COUNTY
ACCOUNTABLE THEM FROM THE
STATE'S PERSPECTIVE WE ALLOCATE
ACCORDING TO THIS MODEL WE GIVE
THE COUNTIES THE MODEL AND THEN
THIS IS A STATE RUN LOCALLY
OPERATED MODEL THIS LOCAL COUNTY
DIRECTORS DO HAVE SOME
DISCRETION IN.
AND DECISION MAKING AS TO HOW
THEY UTILIZE THAT FUNDING. ONE
OF THE SUGGESTIONS FROM STAFF LA --
IS THE NEED TO ADOPT FORMALIZED
METHODOLOGY WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE --
RESPONSE TO THAT.
SO I AGREE THERE ISN'T NEED TO
ADOPT THE FUNDING METHODOLOGY
FORMALIZING CODIFYING I WOULD BE
HESITANT TO CODIFY THAT
NECESSARILY TODAY WE HAVE A
PRETTY STRONG A METHODOLOGY
THAT'S OUT THERE I THINK WE HAVE
A GOOD FEEL ABOUT WHAT THAT IS --
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HAD A METHODOLOGY IN CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM IN TWENTY YEARS
IT WOULD BE NICE TO SEE THAT
THREE YEARS AND HOW THIS MONEY
IS UTILIZED.
AND HOW THE METHODOLOGY PLAYS
OUT BEFORE YOU OFFICIALLY
CODIFIED BUT IF THERE'S LANGUAGE
OR SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE IN THERE THAT THAT MOVES
TOWARD CODIFYING THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO SO.
WELL I I WOULD ASK.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THAT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OUT WORK WITH OUR STAFF TO
DEVELOP THAT TRADE A BIT TRAILER
BUT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
BUZZ BUDGET A BILL LANGUAGE.
IT IS IMPORTANT WE DO NEED TO
CODIFY IT -- THERE HAS TO BE A
AS WAS AS WAS NOTED BY THE LA --
MORE FORMALIZED METHODOLOGY -- I
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE A FEEL FOR IT.
UNFORTUNATELY.
OR FORTUNATELY I I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT?
FINALLY GETTING.
OF THE ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT HAS
BEEN NEEDED FOR SO LONG.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE DO HAVE
THE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR IT AND
THAT -- YOU FOR EXPECTING THE
COUNTIES TO SPEND IT IN A
PARTICULAR WAY.
AND THEY HAVE TO REPORT THERE
HAS TO BE A THE METHODOLOGY SET
IN PLACE AND THAT HAS TO BE FROM
THE STATE.
WE CAN'T LATER SAY WILL CENTER
TO DO YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T DO
WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEIR HANDS ARE GOING TO GO UP
SO WHAT WERE WE SUPPOSED TO DO
WE USE THE MONEY WE DID
EVERYTHING THE WAY WE FELT WE
SHOULD DO IT.
AND THAT WOULD BE TRUE FOR
EVERYONE OF THE COUNTIES.
I WANT MY COUNTY AND I AND
EVERYBODY ELSE WANTS THEIR
COUNTY TO RECEIVE THE MONEY THAT
IS SO SO NEEDED.
I THINK WE WE WOULD ALL AGREE
WITH EVERY EVERY COMMENT THAT
WAS MADE ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE CHILDREN
IN DEEP POVERTY.
THIS IS MONEY THAT IS NEEDED.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BE PRUDENT
WITH WITH WHAT WE ASK OF OUR
COUNTIES.
ONCE THE MONEY IS GIVEN.
WE CAN'T GIVE IT AND THEN LATER
SAY WHAT DID YOU DO IT DID YOU
DO WHAT.
AT THE THE METHODOLOGY DOES HAVE
TO BE SET UP SO I I WOULD ASK
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT ALL.
MEET WITH STAFF TO TRY TO COME
UP WITH THE LANGUAGE THAT THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED. TO BE HAPPY TO
DO SO.
THANK YOU -- I'D I'D ALSO --
ELSE THE TO TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE COLLECTED
COLLECTIBILITY STUDIED -- AT
YOU'VE ALREADY UNDERTAKEN AT YOU
SAY YOU HAVE YOUR A ROUGH DRAFT
CAN WE GET MORE DETAILS -- MORE
SUBSTANCE -- TIME LINES CAN WE
GET THAT BY MAY FIRST.
YES AT LEAST A DRAFT IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
ABSOLUTELY JUST YES YOU'VE GOT
UNTIL JULY FIRST BUT IF WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOME LANGUAGE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE WHERE WE ARE.
OKAY AND DISCOVER THAT STILL
IMAGES DUE JULY FIRST THERE WAS
ANOTHER COMMENT ABOUT
EFFECTIVELY STATE IT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND THAT FOLKS ARE WANTING
US TO REDO BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE THE THE STUDY THAT IS
DUE.
JULY FIRST YES YOU'VE GOT A
ROUGH DRAFT.
YES THAT IS WHAT I'D LIKE FOR
YOU TO SHARE WITH STAFF.
ALL RIGHT AND MAY FIRST.
WE WILL DO OUR VERY BEST.
I KNOW YOU WILL.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
OUR THIS BILL CHECK MYSELF.
CENTER.
YES MISTER FRAZIER WE TALK ABOUT
THE METHODOLOGY YOU LOOK ON PAGE.
TWENTY FIVE TO MY COUNTIES
SOLANO IS 3% AUGMENTATION -- AND
THEN CONTRA COSTA IS 15% I THINK
IT EQUATES TO TWO MILLION. FOR
CONTRA COSTA AND IN ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SOLANO COUNTY.
WHEN YOU PUT THESE NUMBERS OUT
ARE YOU AT?
ATTEMPTING TO TALK TO THESE
COUNTIES AND SAY LISTEN.
I MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SKEWED -- CHART HERE.
AND THEY SAY THAT THIS IS GOING
TO WORK FOR THEM.
IN OR HOW DO YOU RESPOND.
TO POSSIBLY UNDER FUNDING
[inaudible]
OR HARMING.
THE ABILITY TO CARE FOR CHILDREN.
THE WAY WE WENT ABOUT A PLEA
SURE THE WAY WE WENT ABOUT DOING
THE METHODOLOGY WHAT.
THIS THE STATE DEPARTMENT DID
NOT WANT TO TAKE A POSITION TO
SAY THIS IS WHAT THE FUNDING
THAT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE DO YOU
AGREE OR NOT WITH THE LOCAL
CHANNELS FOR AGENCIES THE THIRD
THE THE DRIVE FROM US WAS TO
ENGAGE THE TRUCKS WERE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
HAVE THEM REALLY WORK ON AND THE
THE STUDY TO SEE HOW MUCH TIME
AND ENERGY IT TAKES TO WORK
CASES AND HAVE THEM WORK ON THAT
PROPOSED METHODOLOGY COME TO
AGREEMENT FROM THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE ON THE KIND OF THE
CORE OUT LIKE.
IN IN IN AGREE TO THAT WITH US
SO WE'VE ALREADY GOT THERE BY IN
ON THE FUNDING MYTHOLOGY BECAUSE
THEY WERE ONE OF THE PRIMARY
DRIVERS FOR DEVELOPING.
RIGHT IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE LAMAR.
AND I THINK THAT WE I'M SORRY.
I WAS GOING.
BUT THAT WELL MISTER FRAZIER
WOULD YOU LOOK AT PAGE
[inaudible]
TWENTY THREE BECAUSE THAT THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME.
WHICH WHICH WHICH COUNTY DO WE
SEE AT THE VERY BOTTOM.
WAIT A MINUTE AND NOW WE HAVE A
NEW CHAIR.
NO.
I HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS
[inaudible]
ANY HELP.
THEN IT HELPS I JUST LIVE NO
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE THE LARGEST
COUNTY AND YOU SEE THEY ARE DEAD
LAST.
I I DO APPRECIATE THAT LONG
BEFORE I WAS APPOINTED TO THIS
POSITION THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS DONE INDEPENDENTLY TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE DO WITH THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN DEEP POVERTY.
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HELP AND BY THIS THE
GOVERNOR THEN PROPOSING -- TO TO
ADD THE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
BUT ALSO MENTION IN THE SPRING
TWO YEARS AGO WE WERE WORKING ON
A METHODOLOGY THE RATIO IS
ACTUALLY HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
CASES PER FULL TIME EQUIVALENT.
AFTER THE STUDY DONE BY THE
COUNTIES THEY CAME BACK AND
AGREED THAT IT WAS A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT CASES CRAFTY SO
EVEN THROUGH THEIR ANALYSIS THE
RATIO IS ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN IT
WAS INITIALLY -- KIND OF
BRINGING DOWN THE OVERALL ASK
THAT WERE HERE.
TALKING WITH YOU ABOUT TODAY.
IN ONE LAST QUESTION.
OF I WANT TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THE ON INCREASING THE PASSED
THROUGH TO THE FEDERALLY
ALLOWABLE TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR SYSTEMS -- A TO FAMILIES SO
THERE'S ACTUALLY A A BILL
WORKING ITS WAY THROUGH RIGHT
NOW ON ON THE PASSED THROUGH
WE'VE HAD A PRETTY TIGHT --
CONTROL ON THAT HERE IT HAS BEEN
FIFTY DOLLARS DISREGARD IS
PASSED THE FAMILY THE BALANCES
RECOUP TEN RETURN TO THE STATE
SO -- FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE I'M
I'M REALLY LOOKING TO THE STATE
AS A WHOLE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AN
INNOCENTLY INCIDENT AS OUR
CLIENTS HOW MUCH CHILD SUPPORT
YOU WANTS TO COLLECT ON BEHALF
THE STATE AND HOW MUCH OF IT
WOULD YOU PREFER THAT WE PASSED
TO THE FAMILIES AND SO.
AM WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS
AT THIS POINT WE'RE PRETTY
NEUTRAL ON WHERE THIS NEEDS TO
GO WE'RE GIVING TECHNICAL ADVICE
ON THE IMPACTS OF THAT DECISION
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
SO AS OF NOW THE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NEUTRAL ON
THIS YES.
OKAY WHEN A TAPE POSITION AT
THIS TIME.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
AND I I THINK YOU WERE GOING TO
MAKE A COMMENT.
THE LAST WORD DECEMBER TODAY NO
I'M GOOD I'M GOOD ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING ON AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO TO ALL OF OUR COUNTIES --
WHERE THERE WERE GETTING A SMALL
AMOUNT OR A LARGE AMUNT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TRY TO
HELP THESE CHILDREN?
IN THE END SO THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ISSUE FOR ADVOCACY PROPOSALS FOR
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
YEAH.
WE HAVE JAMIE AUSTIN SENIOR
DIRECTOR INSIDE AND ANALYTICS
TIPPING POINT.
REPLACING JESSICA [inaudible]
RIGHT YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JAMIE
AUSTIN HERE DIRECTOR TO BE POINT
COMMUNITY.
GRANT MAKING ORGANIZATION TO
FIGHT POVERTY THE BAY AREA.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE TO THE
POINT IS RAISE MORE THAN TWO AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
BEST PARTY FIGHTING.
NONPROFITS TO EDUCATE EMPLOY
HOUSE AND SUPPORT THOSE IN NEED.
OUR LAST MONTH TIPPING POINT
COOPER THE PAY BACK PROBLEM THAT
DISCUSSES HOW EVERY YEAR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN LIVING IN
POVERTY TO NOT RECEIVE ALL OF
THEIR CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
MADE BY THEIR PARENTS.
INSTEAD MOST OF THEIR PARENTS
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS ARE
INTERCEPTED BY THE GOVERNMENT TO
PAY BACK THE COST OF TEN F..
MEDI CAL AND OTHER FORMS OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND NOT TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
TIPPING POINT ON BEHALF OF THE
INSIGHT CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT POLICY LINK
THE SAM'S IS GOV FINANCIAL
JUSTICE PROJECT.
AND WESTERN CENTER AMMAN PARTY --
IS HERE DISCUSS THIS REQUEST FOR
INCREASED BUDGET BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT SOME OF THE
COLLECTION STRATEGIES SHOULD BE
TIED TO THIS ASK.
ON THE FIRST OF THE ADVOCATES
REQUESTS.
ARE WE'RE DROPPING A REQUEST FOR
THE COLLECTIBILITY STUDY AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT DEPARTMENT IS
ALREADY COMMITTED TO DOING THIS.
AND THE SECOND REQUEST DRIVER'S
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION SINCE THE SENATE
HEARING ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT TO REVIEW WHEN NON CUSTODIAL
PARENTS CANNOT REPAY THE COST OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND FALL MORE
THAN THIRTY DAYS BEHIND THE
PROCESS FOR SUSPENDING DRIVER'S
LICENSES BEGINS.
AND THE SUSPENSION OF BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONAL LICENSES WORKS
SIMILARLY.
THESE POLICIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
INCOME FAMILIES OF COLOR IS
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF
NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN OR LATINO.
AND BY OUR ESTIMATE A MAJORITY
OF THEM MAKE LESS THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THESE PENALTIES ARE AND JUST
KIND OF PRODUCTIVE AND
UNDERMINED FAMILY ENGAGEMENT.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S MOST STRINGENT
POLICIES REGARDING DRIVER'S
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS.
WHEN PARENTS LOSE A LICENSES
THEY CANNOT DRIVE TO WORK AND
THAT'S REDUCING A MEANS TO PAY
CHILD SUPPORT?
CALIFORNIA ELIMINATED DRIVER'S
LICENSE SUSPENSION FOR FAILING
TO PAY TRAFFIC COURT THAT THAT
MAINTAINS A STRINGENT POLICY FOR
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT.
WE UNDERSTAND IS LOTS OF WORK TO
BE DONE ON THIS ISSUE.
ON THE THIRD REQUEST
INCARCERATION.
I WENT EVEN WHEN DEBT IS OWED TO
THE GOVERNMENTS TO REPAY PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNTIES CAN
INCARCERATE FOR FAILURE TO PAY
CHILD SUPPORT THAT.
THE NUMBERS MAY BE SMALL.
WHEN PARENTS ARE INCARCERATED
THEIR PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PAID
BACK GROWS EXPONENTIALLY AS THE
INTEREST RATE ON THIS DEBT IS
10%?
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REQUIRE THAT A PARENT IS PROVEN
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY THEIR
SUPPORT OWED BEFORE THE COURT
CAN ISSUE A CONTEMPT ORDER. ONE
COURSE RATE AND A CURSORY
APPARENT FOR NON PAYMENT.
THIS WILL NOT ONLY PREVENT
PARENTS FROM BEING INCARCERATED
DUE TO POVERTY.
WILL ALSO BRING CALIFORNIA IN
ALIGNMENT WITH FEDERAL LAW.
AS REQUIRED BY THE OBAMACARE A
FINAL RULE AND THE SUPREME COURT
CASE TURNER VERSES ROGERS.
MARCH ROBIN WITH THE PARENTS --
DRIVEN DEEPER INTO POVERTY IN
THE HIGHER LEVELS OF THAT THE
DRIVERS LICENSE SUSPENSIONS AND
INCARCERATION SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
MEANS TO KEEP UP WITH OUR
PAYMENTS. TO SPENDING DRIVERS
THE VESSEL IN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE AND PARTICULAR CAN KERR
SERRATION FOR EVEN A SMALL
AMOUNT OF TRANSPORT THAT ISN'T
I'M JUST PRACTICE.
IN SERVE ONLY TO REDUCE APPARENT
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN FAMILIES.
WE SUPPORT THE TRAILER BILL TO
AND INEFFICIENT AND HARMFUL
PRACTICES WE WOULD APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS -- ON
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
YOU KNOW AND THIS.
ONE WHICH WAS OFF ON A FINANCE
WANTING POSITION AT THIS TIME I
JUST ALSO RECEIVE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE SO WE'RE STILL
GOING THROUGH IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- DAVID OVER AGAIN
FOR THE DEPARTMENT WE HAVE ALSO
JUST RECEIVED THE TRAILING
REGION HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH
IT AND HAVE SOME ANALYSIS.
ON THIS BASED OFF LAST TIME BUT
WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A
POSITION ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
I THINK -- THAT THE FIRST POINT
THAT HE MENTIONED ABOUT THE THIS
THE STUDY BEING DONE
COLLECTIVELY STUDY THAT WAS THE
OTHER STUDY I WAS REFERRING TO
EARLIER.
THAT WAS DONE IN EARLY TWO
THOUSAND AND TALKS ABOUT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY CLICKED ON CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM SO WE HAVE
INITIATED IN.
A STATEMENT WORKING OR GOING OUT
TO BID TO HAVE THAT STUDY
UPDATED AND FOR A CALIFORNIA TO
TO REALLY SEE HOW THAT MIGHT
IMPACT OUR PROGRAM -- I DO HAVE
MORE CONCERNS ABOUT THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE LANGUAGE IN THERE AND
THAT WE HAVE SOME PROBLEMS WITH
HOW WE WOULD IMPLEMENT THAT TEN
AND ITS EFFECT WHILE I AGREE
WITH THE PREMISE OF OF A
DISPROPORTIONATE VICTIM POVERTY
I THINK THE WAY THAT THAT'S
WHERE THE WRITTEN HERE MIGHT.
BE CHALLENGING FOR US.
AS TO THEIR INCARCERATION PIECE
ON ON ON CONTEMPT.
THERE'S ALREADY THE FINAL RULE
THAT WILL WORK IN IMPLEMENTING A
PEACE THAT FINAL RULES ABOUT
REDUCING.
THE CONTENT PROCESS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A GRANT GOING ON IN SAN
BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE. NINETY TWO
REVIEW THIS AND TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE ARE -- PROCEDURAL.
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CONTEMPT
PROCESS AND SO THAT'S BEEN A
THREE YEAR STUDY.
WELL ACTUALLY IT'S FIVE OR STUDY
BUT THREE YEARS AT THAT THEY'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF ACTUALLY
TESTING THESE RESULTS ON WE'RE
ANTICIPATING SOME POSITIVE
FEEDBACK FROM THOSE.
COMPANY OVERALL EXPECTATION THE
FINAL RULE IS ACTUALLY TO
DECREASE -- DAY THE CONTEMPT
PROCESS AND CERTAINLY NOT
PUTTING PEOPLE IN JAIL AS
REQUESTED.
BUT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT -- NEXT
WITNESS.
HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT LEGISLATURE DID
STAFF MANY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN THIS UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JESSICA BARTLETT
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI SABRINA HAMMER THE CALIFORNIA
AT THE BUILDING COALITION -- WE
SUPPORT POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO
HELP LOW INCOME PEOPLE GET OUT
OF POVERTY YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF A CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENT
SYSTEM 1100% OF PAYMENTS GO
DIRECTLY TO CHILDREN.
NOT -- RECOUPED BY BY THE
GOVERNMENT IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF NOT
UNDERMINING ANY -- NOT THE TOTAL
PARENTS ABILITY TO REAP TO PAY
THOSE PAYMENTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF ANYONE WITH THE CSU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN WORKERS AND
WE CAN COUNTY THE BOARD THE
COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN DOES NOT HAVE
A POSITION ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE HOWEVER.
AS A CHILD FOR PROFESSIONAL OF
TWENTY NINE YEARS I WOULD SAY
THAT THESE PROPOSALS ARE NOT
GOOD FOR THE CHILD FOR AGENCIES.
AND THEY ARE NOT GOOD FOR THE
COST TO PARENTS WHO WOULD REAP
OUR COLLECTION EFFORTS.
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE.
REMEDY RIGHT NOW ALLOWS A LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY. TO SUBMIT
A REQUEST FOR SOMEONE WHO IS
FAILED TO PAY HIS OR HER CHILD
SUPPORT.
IF WE WERE TO HAVE TO GO TO
COURT THAT WOULD.
BE DELAYED THE TIME FOR US TO
THAT COLLECTION AND GET THAT
MONEY TO THE FAMILIES SO I THINK
THAT WOULD HAVE A VERY NEGATIVE
EFFECT.
ON THE CHILDREN FAMILIES WE
SERVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO ARE ONCE AGAIN GREG WILSON
WITH THE CHARLES WHAT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THAT ORGANIZATION WE
ALSO AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
JUST RECEIVED -- NOT LESS THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AGO COPY OF
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND WE
ARE STILL WORKING THROUGH
ANALYZING -- THE DETAILS OF THAT
IS QUITE EXTENSIVE IT'S TWENTY
PAGES LONG IT WILL TAKE SOME
TIME WE DO SEE SOME INITIAL
CHALLENGES -- AND WE ARE MUCH
MORE WE ARE VERY WILLING TO WORK
WITH -- THE COALITION TO DEVELOP
EFFECTIVE LANGUAGE -- THAT IS
BENEFICIAL FOR IT NOT ONLY THE
FAMILIES BUT ALSO THE STATE --
AND THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS SO --
WE OFFER OUR SUPPORT -- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
ITEM AT THE MOMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ANTHONY ROBLES
THAT THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
IN LA AND THAT SOMEBODY HAS BEEN
PERSONALLY IMPACTED BY.
CURRENT CHILD SUPPORT POLICIES
ON MY FATHER WAS INCARCERATED
AND ON WHEN HE GOT OUT YOU KNOW
HE ACCRUED ALL KIND THE CHILD
SUPPORT THAT.
HE OVER HAPPY CHECK WITH CARNAGE
TWENTY FIRST CAME ON A STARTED
WORKING AND NONE OF THAT MONEY
OR VERY LITTLE OF THAT MONEY
EVER GOT BACK TO US -- SO AS
SOMEBODY THAT'S BEEN IMPACTED
THAT WE HAVEN'T SUPPORT ANY ALL
GOOD CHILD SUPPORT POLICIES ON
PHONE SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU. TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
SO.
I CAN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
AT A COMPOUNDS IN AND CREATES
MORE.
BAD THAN GOOD -- WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT -- REVOKING A DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN.
A LOT OF THE SITUATIONS.
SO WHERE IS THE DETERRENT
EFFECTS TAKEN AWAY.
I THINK I'D BE A BIT OF THE
DEPARTMENT DETERMINE I THINK IN
THIS INCIDENT YOU'RE MAKING THE
SUGGESTION I MAKE THIS.
SO YOU NEED TO BRING THE
SOLUTION ALL THEY ALL CALL TURN
OF ALSO.
I MEAN YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE.
IF YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ONE
ALTERNATIVE YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE.
THE OTHER SAID DON'T LEAVE IT TO
THEM.
YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT TO BE
SUPPORTED THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING
WHAT'S THE ALTERNATIVE OR WORDS
THE DETERRENT -- AND I AGREE
WITH YOU.
BUT JUST DON'T HANDED OFF AND
SAY WE WANT THIS AND THEN.
BE A PART OF THE SOLUTION WHAT
WILL BE THE DETERRENT.
I BECAUSE AS IT THE OTHERS WHO
HAVE STATED.
IN ARMS THE CHILDREN.
SO HERE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
PEOPLE HAVE [inaudible]
A REASON. TO NOT SKIP OUT.
AND KNOWING THAT THAT NOW IF WE
TAKE THAT AWAY.
WHAT'S THE DETERRENT SITE YOU
KNOW DEPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
THE AGENCY -- TO CREATE THE
POSSIBILITY.
OF BECAUSE IF NOT.
THERE'S NO OTHER ALL DETERRENT.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED ALTHOUGH
TO KEEP IT.
YEAH I WOULD I WOULD.
AGREE WITH -- MISTER FRASIER'S
COMMENTS THAT IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT TO US IT'S OBVIOUS
WHAT YOU DON'T WANT.
BUT IT'S NOT OBVIOUS WHAT YOU DO
[inaudible]
AND SO.
YOU KNOW IT ISN'T REALLY I MEAN
WILL WILL REACT TO WHAT YOU
BRING FORWARD AS AS ADVOCATES
AND AGREE THERE'S A WEEK WE
THERE ARE PROBLEMS AND WE DO WE
DO BUT WE DON'T DON'T WANT TO
SEE CHILDREN HARM.
BUT I DO TO HAVE A CONCERN THAT
WITH WITH THERE'S NO DETERRENT
THAN.
HOW DOES HOW DOES HOW DOES THIS
ULTIMATELY WORK OUT FOR THE KIDS?
THIS IS A KIND OF A LOT TO WORTH
IT BUT DEPARTMENT ON THIS I'D
LOVE FOR YOU TO PICK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE I DO WANT TO ASK
THE DIRECTOR -- HOW WIDESPREAD
THE PENAL CODE VIOLATION OF
CONTEMPT?
ARE USED AS TOOLS CONTENT.
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CONTENT THERE'S A CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT IN A CIVIL CONTEMPT
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT IS A VERY
COSTLY PROGRAMMING HAS BEEN
VIRTUALLY COMPLETELY ELIMINATE
ACROSS ALL THE COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND THE IDEA OF GOING AFTER AND
CREATING SOME SORT OF CRIMINAL
VIOLATION IN THE PUTTING SOMEONE
IN JAIL BECAUSE OF CHILD SUPPORT
IS CLEARLY NOT GOING TO IMPROVE
THE BENEFIT.
AND TO THE CHILD THAT THE PERSON
NEEDS TO BE OUT NEED BE WORKING
THE CIVIL CONTEMPT IS A PROCESS
THAT WE USE -- PRIMARILY AS A
TOOL TO GET SOMEONE INTO OUR
OFFICE AND ENGAGE WITH THAT AS
LONG AS THEY'RE ENGAGING WITH US
WE DON'T MOVE.
THE FOLKS AT IGNORE US THAT
TENDS TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
PROCESS AND I DON'T THINK THAT.
AND THE FINAL CONTEMPT RESULT
ACTUALLY HELPS THEM IT PROBABLY
HURTS THEM MORE FROM GETTING
THEIR JOB BUT LACKING THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR CONTEMPT
ACTION TO SPUR SOMEBODY TO
ENGAGE WITH US.
WE DO STRUGGLE WITH GETTING
SOMEONE.
TO OPEN THEIR MAIL OR CALL US
SOARING ENGAGE WITH US IN ANY
SORT OF HUESO.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE CONTENT
PROCESSES USED -- FOR I CAN'T
THINK OF A TIME WHEN WE PUT
SOMEONE IN JAIL BECAUSE OF CHILD
SUPPORT STILLER CRIMINAL I'D
HAVE TO GO BACK.
A LONG WAYS TO FIND ONE OF THOSE
EXAMPLES AND BUT THERE ARE
INCIDENCES AND HE'S SPEAKING
MORE TO FOLKS THAT ARE IN
POVERTY AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT
THE CONTEMPT PROCESS ITSELF IS
MOST BENEFICIAL WHEN WE ACTIVELY
KNOW SOMEONE IS HIDING FROM US
OR ATTEMPTING TO AVOID US AND
THAT.
IS OUR ONE OF OUR STRONGEST
REMEDIES TO REALLY GET THE COR
INVOLVED AND MAKE SOMEONE PAY
WHO HAS THE KEPT CAPABILITY AND
THE CAPACITY TO PAY BUT IS JUST
ACTIVELY CHOOSING NOT.
TO YES MOST FRESH.
IS THERE A NUMBER THAT YOU HAVE.
THAT IS COLLECTIBLE RIGHT NOW.
TO ALL OF THE FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE NEEDS TO BE COLLECTED.
WELL THE ARREARS BALANCE IN
CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ARREARS DO.
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS INTEREST?
A BIG PORTION OF THAT IS
INTERESTS AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF
10% RATE NAM I AM BELIEVE FOR AT
ABOUT NINE MILLION OR EIGHT
MILLION IN PRINCIPLE ON THE
BALANCE IN INTEREST.
BUT OKAY THOSE NUMBERS BECAUSE
I'M GOING OFF TOP OF MY HEAD.
IS THERE EVER BEEN A PROGRAM
THAT WOULD WAIVE THE WILL
INTEREST IF IT WAS A MADE.
OF THERE ARE OTHER STATES THAT
WAVE THE INTEREST TO AND THE
CHANCE FOR PROGRAM THE ONLY
COLLECT PRINCIPLE THERE ARE
STATES THAT HAVE A 0% INTEREST
RATE 3% INTEREST RATE CALIFORNIA
IS SET AT TEN AND THAT'S THAT
ACROSS ALL OF THE JUDICIAL
MATTERS SO IT'S NOT JUST OUR
INTEREST.
RATE BUT IT CAN BE CARVED OUT IF
IF THE RULING WHICH TO DO THAT
AND THERE ARE ACTUAL PROPOSALS
THEY'RE GOING TO THE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
THAT SPEAKING TO INTEREST RATES
MAYBE 10% IS NOT THE RIGHT
NUMBER FOR AND I KNOW THE DMV
DOES THOSE -- CRASH.
WHERE THE WIPEOUT?
AMNESTY PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR
THE WORD YOU KNOW.
WE WILL WAIVE THE INTEREST IF
YOU IF YOU CATCH UP.
HAS THAT EVER BEEN DONE SO WE DO
HAVE A CO PROGRAM THAT IS
AMNESTY AND USUALLY IF SOMEONE
IS PAYING 10% OF WHAT'S OUT NOW
THIS IS SPECIFICALLY THE
GOVERNMENT WE DON'T WAVE --
MOTHERS ARE STILL DEPARTMENT
JUST THE FOR THE GOVERNMENT --
USUALLY IF SOMEONE IS PAYING TO
PAY A LUMP SUM OF THEY PAY
OVERTIME WILL WIPE UP 290% OF
THE DEBT OWED TO THE GOVERNMENT --
FOR FOLKS THAT ARE TRYING TO GET
BACK ON TOP OF THEIR LIFE AND AM
IN WILLING TO PAY SO WE DO HAVE
THAT PROCESS THERE.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE PROPOSAL'S
GOING TO TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
OWED TO THE GOVERNMENT AND
WHETHER WERE WILLING TO WAIVE
FOR WIPE THAT OUT TO CLOSE THE
CASE IN ENTIRETY.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE FINAL
RULE AND IT'S PART OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE WORKING THE
WAY TO THE SYSTEM RIGHT NOW.
SO IS IT SOMETHING THAT --
CALIFORNIA CAN ADOPT. FOR
INSTANCE A ONE OR TWO YEAR
AMNESTY PROGRAM. TO COLLECT.
THE ARREARS.
I'M NOT SURE ADDRESSING.
IF THE THE THE CHILD SUPPORT
THAT IS OWED ON THE BOOKS.
IS.
WHAT DID YOU SAVE OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION?
AND THEN THE REST WAS ALL
INTEREST YEAH THERE'S SAID ABOUT
A BILLION -- TO ODIN PRINCIPAL
AND THEN THE THE BALANCES OWED
AN INTEREST -- IN NOW THAT'S THE
GRAND TOTAL THERE'S A SMALLER
PORTION IT'S OWED SPECIFICALLY
TO THE STATE AND PRINCIPAL AND
INTEREST WHICH IS A BIG TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS WORK IN A
WAY THROUGH.
AND THAT'S REALLY FROM THE
STATE'S TOLERANCE LEVEL AS TO
HOW MUCH WE'RE WILLING TO WAVER
FORGIVE THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
I HAVE A QUESTION THAT YOU NEW
YORK HAS A NEW PROPOSAL NEW
PROGRAM -- PROPERTY PROGRAMMER
ORDER ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH IT.
NOW I WAS GETTING AT QUICK LOS
ANGELES YEAH.
IN THAT WE CAN SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD RECENTLY
BEEN TALKING ABOUT WHAT NEW YORK
STATE IS DONE RECENTLY TO
ADDRESS THE HUGE ON BURGEONING
ARREARS PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE A POVERTY LEVEL ORDER
AND A MINIMUM ORDER THE POVERTY
LEVEL ORDER IS SET WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL. FOR INSTANCE IN A
STUDY APPARENT HIS INCOME IS
BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
THE COURT THEN ESTABLISHES THE
ORDER TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
HAS MULTIPLE USES AND BENEFITS
ONE IS A GETS THE KNOX SO THE
APPARENT CONNECTED. TO THE
CUSTODIAL PARENT AND THE CHILD
BECAUSE THEY SEE THE PAYMENTS
ARE BEING MADE.
AS OPPOSED TO A ZERO ORDER OR IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO ASSUME IF
WE HAVE NO WARNINGS HISTORY.
THAT THE PARENT IS WORKING FULL
TIME AT MINIMUM WAGE AND THAT'S
PUT INTO OUR CALCULATOR THEY END
UP WITH AN ORDER THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DOLLARS AND THEY
CAN'T PAY WHY NOT GIVE THEM IN
ORDER THAT THEY CAN PAY.
IT THROUGH THE BELOW THE FEDERAL
POVERTY POVERTY LEVEL TO GET
THEM STARTED WE CAN ALWAYS
INCREASE IT IF THEY BECOME
EMPLOYED.
THEN THE OTHER FIFTY DOLLAR
ORDER IN NEW YORK HAS TO DO WITH
SOMEONE BEING BELOW 2100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL I THINK
THERE'S A LOT THERE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING THAT WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN GOING BACK TO TO SOME OF THE
TOOLS ARE USED.
DO.
DO THE PRACTICES WHETHER WERE
USING THE PENAL CODE OR THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
DO THESE PRACTICES IMPROVE
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT.
IT'S VERY HARD FOR US TO
DETERMINE WHETHER.
THE FAMILY THE MOM AND DAD ARE
ACTUALLY TALKING TO EACH OTHER
AND NOT TO OR WHETHER CHILD
SUPPORT IS THE IS THE THING
THAT'S BRINGING THEM TOGETHER AT
THE THING THAT'S KEEPING THEM
APART -- I THINK IT'S HAPPENING
BOTH WAYS RIGHT NOW -- BECAUSE
WE'RE WE HAVE THAT CHILD SUPPORT
ORDER RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
EVERYTHING SO THAT I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW WELL WE ARE CREATING AN
ENGAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE PER SE OR
A SEPARATION BECAUSE WE'RE
EXPECTING A PERSON PAY THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT AND THEY MIGHT BE
UPSET ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT TWO THIRDS.
OF NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS THAT ARE
IN ARREARS ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO -- IT THEY ARE ALSO --
AT BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR.
THAT HAS TO BE CONSIDERED WE
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO COLLECT THE
CHILD SUPPORT THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE RULES AND
HOW THEY AFFECT THOSE WHO CAN
LEAST.
AFFORD TO HAVE.
HAVE THE RULES SET IN SUCH A WAY
THAT IT JUST PUTS THEM FURTHER
AND FURTHER NOT ONLY FOR THE
FURTHER INTO POVERTY.
BUT ALSO FURTHER AND FURTHER
INTO THE SHADOWS.
AND THEN THAT WORKS JUST EXACTLY
AGAINST FAMILY ENGAGEMENT WHICH
BECOMES A SERIOUSPROBLEM I
THINK NEW YORK MAY BE ON TO
SOMETHING -- MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WE SHOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT BUT I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE -- THE THE THE
PRESENTATION THE PROPOSAL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD I THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND BEFORE WE CONCLUDE I WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN UP A TO PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ANY OF THE NON
DISCUSSION ISSUES IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE -- TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THIS COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED